Hi my name is Carol goldsmith on
the president of Fresno City
College nam behalf of that
Fresno City College staff and
students. Are which by the way
if you haven't hurt California's
first community college.
Along with my sister colleges
in Clovis in Ridley. And that
the other centers in this great
state Senate communicative
district.
I which serves well over fifty
five thousand students pursuing
their educational goals it is my
distinct pleasure to welcome
each and everyone of you here
today.
As evidenced by today's agenda
this informational hearing is
designed to focus on ensuring
the matter Ste master plan.
Meets the needs of students.
A special thank you to
assemblyman Berman. Joaquin
Arambula.
And others and the other states
a skewed other nurses and the
first half but making sure the
Savannah goes off without a
hitch.
I'd also like to think a a few
of the notable dignitaries that
are in the audience first and
foremost as my boss Dr Pol Pot
held chancellor of the great
state Senate committee because
district.
Justine Deborah I cannot.
My fellow sister and comrade in
arms doctor Lori Bennett Clovis
communicant.
I know that we also a doctor
Jones from Fresno Pacific
university joining us thank you
Sir for being here.
Yes I have been to ran from the
Central Valley higher and
consortium joining us.
And if I've missed anyone else
my sincere apologies.
Again.
.
I know my one I think own I
think all of the students.
My local students and students
who've traveled great distances
to be with us today.
I'm looking forward to hearing
your voices on how we can ensure
the California master plan may
better meet the needs
all students.
An as a historian I would be
remiss if I didn't take a moment
to talk just.
For a second about how important
stays to our future. By
highlighting our past.
The post World War two era has
had significant.
Impact on the reorganization of
American higher education.
Of the approximately seventeen
states during the late nineteen
fifties and sixties that
modified their public and
private systems to promote
coordination. Control costs and
insurance system that is built
to educate the public.
None.
None that the massive work that
California did.
That work then resulted in a
system that was the envy of the
world.
During the nineteen fifties
California's. To find the common
vision for higher education
system.
And at the opening of the
negotiation process.
Books have been read about that
tense time.
It was understood by all but the
stakes were extremely high.
For that university of
California for the state's
colleges and more importantly
for the people and future of
California.
I would argue that today the
stakes.
Are even more I.
Clark Kerr the president then of
you see was a key figure in the
development of the at California
master plan.
The plan set up a coherent
system for post secondary
education which to find the
specific roles. Already existing
university of California.
But then California state
college to system of senior
colleges which we now know as
the California State. University
system and the California
community college system.
The plan referred.
He keenly to curse vision and
the role and the importance of
higher education in the mid
twenty century America.
His insights in California's
changing needs and aspirations
with pivotal to the development.
It's development an adaptation
required both pragmatism and
political skill.
These three guys I know are
listening to that last word who
political skill.
It's implementation propelled
California her education to
national and international
prominence.
However. As demographics.
In the years wore on. The
economic and educational
circumstances in realities have
changed over the year.
Young man in the front can you
hold up that device for second.
Fuller pi.
That wasn't around in the
nineteen sixties.
And a think about it much has
changed in the nineteen sixties.
So again I want to welcome all
of you to Fresno City College.
It is my hope that through the
series of informational sessions
we can embody the spirit that
those held during those
courageous conversations of the.
And to be bold in our planning
of our future.
Is my hope that the work that
takes place today and future
sessions will continue to hasten
the planting of the seeds of
hope for our future.
Our mutual trust.
And and ordered Forest to be
removed forward and created new
shared vision how California
will educate its people.
I believe that everyone here on
the panel and everyone in the
audience and those who are
watching online are committed to
making sure that all of our
sister
is work together.
To provide the best.
For our students today. And for
the students of our future.
With the skills that they need
to thrive in the twenty first
century economy. That were
living up to the promises that
we made in the nineteen sixties
the accessibility affordability
and high quality will still
remain. So ladies and gentlemen
again thank you and welcome to
Fresno City College.
Thank you so much doctor
goldsmith.
I think you to your team here
Fresno City College of for your
hospitality and and for working
with with my team. A to make
today's.
Committee hearing a success and
I know it will be.
And also thank you to everyone
is joining us today of this is
the third hearing of the
assembly select committee on the
master.
For higher education
in California. And the series
being recorded and will be
available for viewing online on
the so select committee web page
by as early as tomorrow.
In nineteen sixty California
developed a visionary plan for
the future of higher education
known as the master plan.
However much has changed since
nineteen sixty.
Population growth increase
student diversity a change in
leading industries and their
need for talent. As well as in
the feel of education itself.
Representing Silicon Valley I
see how quickly technology is
advancing along with the rise of
new industry.
Both have altered student needs
and boost demand for higher
education.
We need a higher education
system to respond to a host of
issues never previously
envisioned including the I
thought. Or any smartphones.
My goal for this select
committee is to hold hearings
throughout the state. To conduct
a thorough legislative review to
ensure that California has a
master plan and higher edges
education system for today and
for tomorrow.
We need to keep the state's
promised to our students are
providing and accessible
affordable high quality higher
education
for all California students who
qualify.
The select committee is the
first step in a multi year
endeavor to update the master
plan.
Now I'm coming in with an open
mind. And I do not have any
preconceived notions or
solutions that encourage my
colleagues to do the same.
I do the first two years of the
select committee is being the
information gathering phase
where we hear from all
stakeholders and collect as much
feedback as we can.
The select committee held its
first hearing the last year on
August thirty first in
Sacramento where we heard in
over view and status of higher
education from the legislative
analyst's office.
As well as from the leaders of
California's higher education
institutions specifically the
community colleges the CSU
system the UC system and the
association of nonprofit.
Private institutions.
The second hearing which was
held on November first.
I'd seen it they state
university focused on
California's workforce needs.
At this hearing we heard from
academics as well as the
business community about the
workforce skills gap never
facing in California.
In addition to today's hearing
plan to hold two more hearings
this year. One in southern
California with a focus on the
needs of faculty and staff. And
one back in Sacramento to
examine cost in funding issues
including financial aid.
After the conclusion of the
hearings the slight committee
was your report. Likely at the
end of this year summarizing the
hearings as well as recommending
the next steps such as what
issues need to be focused on in
more depth.
Today's hearing focusing on the
needs of students will be
student German.
Now with the student kicking off
each panel.
Our hearing will consist of the
following three panels.
The first panel will discuss
affordability and examine the
total cost of attendance. For
students.
In this panel were hit we will
hear from you see students. As
well as from the institute for
cops access and success.
The second panel will discuss
the basic needs of students such
as food mental health and
housing.
And in this panel will hear from
it CSU student as well as
representatives from the public
higher education segment.
The third panel will discuss at
the end student success. Out
where we'll hear from a
community college student a
Fresno Pacific university
student.
The campaign for college
opportunity and the Central
Valley higher education
consortium.
And also be an opportune at the
end for public comment.
At the end of the hearing and
with a sign up sheet for folks
who like to speak and I think
the Senate she is.
Out the front door I'm really
one encourage everybody who has
something to say to to
participate public comment.
The subcommittee has a
membership that's appointed on a
bipartisan basis and we are very
fortunate to have members who
have a strong background in
interest in higher education
with us today. Up first and
foremost is is our host.
And your assembly member Dr
Joaquin Arambula.
And without a to have a look in
my colleagues certainly don't
during good.
To say any anywhere is there.
So I just wanted to say it's so
nice. Back home in my backyard
for those of you that don't now
I grew up about a block away
from.
I live less than half a mile
away from here right now and it
really is nice being at the
first City College in our state.
And second in our nation.
I'm particularly proud that my
colleagues wanted to come in
here are voices in our
community.
So often we feel that Sacramento
doesn't hear us
but here we are to hear from
you.
Finally like to say that not one
of us who are here on the panel
were around in the.
Steve.
And that as times change so must
visions.
And what our master plan must do
is meet our needs of today.
And so look forward to hearing
from the students on how we can
better make improvements
and thank you again for being
here at Fresno City.
Thank you doctor England were
also joined.
By senator Ben Allen who is the
chair of the Senate Education
Committee.
Senate Allen.
We'll just. Grabbed just awarded
to thank the organizers every
helped put
together obvious in.
Drive down.
It's really fun to.
Your.
To hear the pride that he.
Is really spent.
They were the top.
So I really appreciate that you
know I by
I served as.
Board member of the.
A little while back.
Ali with the growth
me witnesses.
The growth of.
Saddest
the road
I will surely proud of the sick
is that have
place there but we're also.
Proud of and also.
Concerned about in the broader.
A chap is a needs that are that
are entire public educate.
The faces you
for you and I'm just glad that
they assignor Berman is really
taking on this issue
the very substantive way.
Updating examining our master
plan that was written in
nineteen sixty units will serve
the state so well. Over so many
years and yet there's no
question everybody's mind that.
It deserves a a liver of an
upgrade.
And that's what we're doing with
the subcommittee.
Typically we you know we have a
strange inner house rivalry that
I never quite understand and
Sacramento but I wanted to make
sure that as chair. Of the
committee that oversees
education policy on the Senate
side that I be that participate
in this effort and that's why
I'm here today and.
And.
And excited to hear about. The
stories would be proud for to
our committee today.
I will be focusing a lot
portability questions an
enormous problem statewide.
How young people are being asked
to step up and leverage their
futures and it to levels that I
think previous generations
never could have imagined?
And then exacerbating the cost
that we're putting on to the
the basic cost of education. We
don't have all the enormous
housing costs that. Have just
gone through the roof everywhere
in the state. And it's really
becoming enormous challenge the
wild thing is that now it ends
up that the total cost of
education.
Is actually tends to be higher
for a a. A low income
communicable student who doesn't
live at home.
Verses you see your cal state is
because the least do you see.
They've got you know. Decent
wraparound services.
No for room and board for low
income students and that of
course doesn't exist. Not in any
kind of robust waiter could be
college level so we're we're all
facing enormous challenges right
now as we try to think about how
to move forward.
.
But I I really do applied.
A marketing Joaquin for their
leadership and I'm I'm looking
for to hearing the testimony
today.
Thank you very much senator and
and thank you for your
involvement it's gonna make you
as we move from information
gathering stage to that.
The legislative stages that.
.
In a joint and and close
relationship that we have I
think it's gonna make a lot
smoother. On in both houses
really appreciate you taking
your whole day pretty much out
to come and spend with us.
Is a direct flight to LA them
to catch leader.
And and so our first panel.
Is our do we have a list of.
Perfect and so I think we think
the local elected leaders have
been introduced if anybody was
introduced earlier please let us
know. When it will be happy to
recognize you during the
hearing.
Then so we'll move on our first
panel which is on affordability.
The total cost of attendance for
students.
And select introduced Spenser
Brandt who's a student leader at
UC Santa Barbara.
And W. W. Cochran and vice
president of the institute
for college access
its success thank you so much
for joining us.
It will kick it off for the
presentation from from Spencer.
Good afternoon.
Leyva Spencer brand and I am a
third year student at UC Santa
Barbara I had the privilege of
being here representing the UC
student association.
System wide advocacy group with
a strong history of campus
activism and education policy
advocates he forty two hundred
thousand plus undergraduate.
Graduate and professional you
see students.
It feels good to be here and
Fresno because it feels like
home to me too I grew up in the
Central Valley as did my
parents.
And their parents before them.
I'm cognizant that here in the
Central Valley we lag
significantly behind the rest of
the state in terms of higher
education.
Only thirteen percent of adults
in my home county have acquired
a bachelor's degree.
My family is reflective of that
number.
Throughout my childhood and
teenage years I can remember my
mother always telling me that
she couldn't wait until I went
away to college.
Whether that was because she saw
potential in me or because she
saw an XTC major who she wanted
to get out of the house. I can't
be completely sure.
But more particularly my mother
always stressed to me that the
cost of college shouldn't
prevent me from pursuing higher
degree.
The degree the skills you learn
are worth it she would tell me.
Occasionally this message came
across as the typical modeler
motherly encouragement.
And other times I could hear in
her voice that she was trying to
tell me something else.
Something about her own journey
through life that she regretted.
Something about the
inaccessibility of college when
she was growing up.
In the financial structure it
struggles that had limited her
options.
Despite those odds he had
acquired a degree so I took her
advice and applied to the
schools of my dreams.
All in the California you
perceive California and CSU
system.
I was admitted to UC Santa
Barbara and quickly decided to
attend what was and is still the
most beautiful campus in the
world.
Upon enrolling at UCSB I quickly
learned that the cost of college
for students are not confined to
the classroom.
The cost of college includes
includes books force readers and
lab coats housing Hafen in
saturated markets with
perpetually rising rents.
And food and other basic needs
needed to survive.
Another thing I like for my mom
a kid twelve teacher for more
than a decade is that academic
success does not begin and and
in the classroom.
It extends to every students
home environment.
I have to make tough decisions
about whether to buy every book
that I need for a course. Or to
go to the market in by angry ins
for dinner.
I satellite you're wondering
what it is that I can do to come
up with those extra few dollars
to pay rent.
I maxed out on the amount
student loans I can half.
I can tell you the names of
every financial assistance
program that we have on campus
which ones are grants which ones
are loans. Which ones require
proof of an addiction notice
before they stepped in with
meager systems.
Because I've been searching for
every possible Avenue to pay for
these costs.
I can also tell you that I know
that financial support that
students receive is going to get
smaller before it gets bigger.
This is because our segments of
higher education in the state
are only two pieces in the web
of assistance that is provided
to students.
At the federal level student aid
grant programs have been
decimated.
In nineteen eighty the be all
grant covered seventy seven
percent of the cost of college
attendance.
Today it covers less than one
third of that cost.
Hell is no longer tied to
inflation and uncertainty and
neglect at the federal level
threatens to impose further
financial hardship on students.
In addition increased
enrollments have impacted the
housing markets is for campuses
across the state.
My first year I lived in the
chapel room on campus
in a dorm that was constructed
around the time that my
grandfather was born.
Older friends of mine who had
lived in the same dorm were
shocked that room was a closet
with two people living in it how
do you manage they would say.
Needless to say we were eager to
move out after the first year of
close company.
This year the last freshman
doubles were converted triples
on our campus to accommodate
rising enrollment.
My roommates and I decided to
move out of the residence halls
in in Thailand is set a college
town directly adjacent to you
see center Barbara. With costs
were extensively lower. We begin
searching for housing coming
academic year during December of
our first year school.
We quickly quickly realize that
the only way to find something
halfway affordable was to find
some friends who were going to
pack into an apartment like
sardines.
We settled on a group of six men
six turned to eight and eight to
ten.
Are leasing camp company paid us
no deference and we stop the
unit that we've been eyeing to
another group of students
so we added the final two people
Bataan and signed a lease on the
bottom story of a duplex.
For a grand total of six
thousand eight hundred and fifty
dollars per month.
Well above the cost estimates
posts on the UC website.
My parents agreed to split the
security deposit my share was
fifteen hundred dollars in
total.
Will get about all back I sure
them but my friends and I knew
that I was the landlords are
notorious for getting away with
highway robbery.
Talking thousands and falsely
claim damages every year.
Today as far as our land lord
knows we've E. people living in
our little blue house.
But in reality anywhere from ten
to thirteen people are crammed
into two bedrooms and one garage
on any given night.
Some who are additional sub
Weezer's somewhere France some
more friends that are
experiencing homelessness.
This student aid I receive this
year through cal grant a direct
federal loans comes to hundred
fifty dollars short of covering
the cost of my rent each
quarter.
Needless to say. When I'm not
studying I work to make up the
difference.
While the home environment can
he cramped loud and overwhelming
sometime
at least I can say that I live
with some good for.
Not all students can say that.
Kind of firemen can take a toll
on our students academic
performance.
Cal grant and loans don't cover
the cost of basic needs
either.
As a freshman with the meal plan
I paid almost two thousand a
quarter for nutritious and.
Paid for by special grant given
to first year students.
No but I live off campus I can't
afford be paying ten dollars per
meal so I cook for myself as
often as I can. And buy food and
other basic necessities at the
market down the street.
The prices they're unfortunately
are well above the state
average.
Cal grant does not cover my
costs of living or my cost of
education during the summer
months as well even though my
lease last year round.
Because of the difficulty I have
getting into courses I needed
began content I need to begin
and continue my major. I pursue
taking classes over the summer.
I can't do this at UC Santa
Barbara because cal grant does
not extend into the summer.
This leaves in a time crunch to
take out. As many courses is I
can't of finish my degree in
four years. Before my financial
aid runs out.
I had no idea about any of this
before I step foot on campus.
And parents the trial by fire
that students know all too well.
We need a more accurate and
transparent assessment of these
costs so that they can make some
students can make the right
financial decisions.
Lastly the sleeves of books
quirk breeders and other
educational supplies as a third
consistently under prioritize
because.
I and other
specter
the price of which are rising
faster than housing or tuition
and fees.
These are the true cost of
attendance.
They go far beyond tuition and
fees
students are engaged in the
constant balancing act weighing
their academic attainment
against some of their basic
needs.
In past hearings held by this
committee we've heard about the
importance of making the
university accessible to all
California students.
Especially those that are from
underrepresented communities
including people of color
undocumented students students
for rural communities and
students with disabilities.
If our state wants to claim the
mantle of standing for these
communities and for a vision of
opportunity and social justice.
This is imperative and if our
state wants to meet the needs of
California's a vibrant economy
we must increase the number of
students with degrees and close
the degree gap.
But we do this by investment
first and foremost
the California public higher
education system clearly lacks
the resources. To accomplish the
major task given rolling born
more students without a major
shift in tone on the part of our
lawmakers an executive branch in
regard to funding.
If your has its in to believe me
take a look. At the state of our
campuses right now.
Come visit our classrooms and
sit with students in the aisles
of lecture halls.
Come.
Sorry visit our research labs
and talk to our researchers who
work with aging and dilapidated
equipment.
Caller counseling and
psychological services center
and try to schedule an
appointment.
I can promise you'll wait
anywhere between a day and week
to see a therapist and once you
do follow up visits are
scheduled weeks away if at all.
Now imagine that these
institutions have been rolled
thousands and thousands of more
students without adequate
reinvestment.
And try to tell me that they are
still the number one public
higher education system in the
world.
We must collectively reimagine
the role of higher education in
our state.
I believe every resident must
have the right to attend college
without that without tuition and
without an unbearable cost of
living.
Students on our campus have high
hopes in our collective ability
to produce that long term vision
for public higher education in
our state.
Through it all we must look at
the student experiences our
Guiding Light. Must raise per
student funding in all segments
of higher education.
Lower the cost of attendance for
students and we must work
together by students workers as
faculty as colleges and is
policymakers to make this vision
a reality. I can promise you
that students are ready to do
their part.
Thank you.
Thank you very much Spencer
Spencer and and some of his
peers.
Came to my office.
A month month and a half ago.
To talk with me about their
experiences.
You see S. B. in and how they
really want to be.
Constructive part of this
conversation and and
the patient a day as a huge step
in that direction really
appreciate that.
The very much and next up we
have Debbie Cochran vice
president of the institute for
college access and success
.
Phone.
And thank you so much for having
me here today I am so happy to
be here with you I'm. The
institute for college access and
success is a non prop up it
nonpartisan research and policy
organization based in.
Oakland California.
I'm organizations vice
presidents and I also lead it's
California policy in advocacy
work.
I said I would acknowledge right
now that I'm gonna go through
some of these lights pretty
quickly I actually pulled the
power point together before
writing up what I was going to
say about it you realize I
might.
Been a little too ambitious.
So.
Bear with me.
Are you know I really
appreciate this could this
committee's focus on.
Making sure that the master
plan is meeting the needs of
students and starting off with
affordability in particular
because we at TI guess he
affordability. I'm as very
critical to both students access
to and success in college.
You know if you can't pay the
tuition bill for college then
you can't access college you
can't step foot in the door.
But text books transportation
food housing those are all also
costs of attendance for college
if you only have resources to
cover the tuition melon not
those other costs.
You can't afford to keep coming
back to the classroom day after
day and week after week you
can't afford to visit the
library or visit the tutoring
center or good a professor's
office hours. So those are the
types of costs in this are the
types of financial aid that
students need.
See it in college.
I'm as a state when we look at
the research in the and that.
Day how California compares to
the rest the country we see that
California's on a relatively
good job with making access to
college affordable.
Ya in California young adults
are much more likely to enroll
in college than their peers
nationally.
Our community colleges have the
lowest tuition in the country
and that all of California's
public colleges and universities
about half of students attend
tuition free. And that's really
because we as a state have long
set up our financially policies
to make sure that tuition costs
aren't a barrier to enrolling.
But the state does not do as
good of a job with supporting
students with non tuition costs.
The California SUNY commission
estimates that for twenty
thousand seventeen eighteen.
Full time student living
independently off campus that's
that's the way that most college
students in California at all
three segments lives.
They have on over nineteen
thousand dollars and cost beyond
tuition
so you can see the breakdown on
the slide of how those costs
shake out of. Over nine thousand
dollars in the colleges and
estimates for housing costs as
we just heard those caught those
estimates might even be
realistic.
And now my next two slides are
focused on three public colleges
in the Sacramento area and the
demonstrate how much of it.
To look at total college costs
I'm as opposed to just tuition.
So we look at just tuition
costs.
We can see that the community
college is by far the least
expensive option of that of the
three choices that a Sacramento
areas you might be faced with.
I am in fact the cost of
community college that's quite
low.
But when we add in non tuition
costs the differences shrink and
the entire total costs of
attendance for students at all
three segments.
But much harder at for students
to reach.
Now these are colleges own
estimates of students costs and
we took them from colleges net
price calculators.
I am now the net price of
colleges when it cost students
to actually attend college.
Full cost of college after
taking out all the grantee
that's available to students
I'm sorts when they really need
to pay after granted no net
price calculators are consumer
tools that are designed. To help
prospective students and their
families understand what is
really going tap it costs for a
student to attend a particular
college.
So we looked at the net price
calculators for twenty seven
public colleges.
State.
All nine of the undergraduate
serving UC's and nearby see.
Cao states and community
college campuses because we
wanted to see what it costs for
low income students to attend
each of these schools.
Now we focused on low income
students by which I mean with
family incomes under thirty
thousand dollars of having come
here because analyses of college
affordability across in.
Groups consistently shows that
this is the group that is facing
the most burdensome college
costs.
It's also important to note
however that the majority of
African American Latino and give
American students have family
incomes under thirty thousand
dollars.
So looking at net price
calculator as we can see. And
review how well you can see that
on that on the screen you can
see that our sample students
that we that we looked at that
price calculators for would
receive more than enough granted
to cover their tuition at each
of the.
Colleges but they're still left
with net prices that would
require them to borrow loans or
work long hours to afford.
As senator Alan put it so well
in his introductory remarks I'm
in most regions of the state
including here and the Central
Valley this community colleges
actually be most expensive
option. For students.
Now in twenty sixteen we
surveyed twelve thousand
California community college
students about the trade offs
that they face in pain for
college. And the overwhelmingly
discuss the challenges posed by
their non tuition costs.
Many students shared stories
about their struggles with
homelessness or near
homelessness and pointed out
specifically how little
financial aid is available to
help students with those costs.
Students shared stories about
having to choose between buying
textbooks and eating.
Many students I have pointed to
the cost of textbooks as being
unrealistically high such as two
hundred dollars with one student
even. Asking very directly how
is a low income students
supposed to afford this.
It was part of this same study
we ask students what they are
likely to do you if they cannot
afford required text.
One third of them said that they
would do what they could to pass
our forces without the books.
Twenty seven percent said they
were likely to drop the course.
So this exemplifies how students
when faced with on affordable
college costs
make choices that influence
whether the graduate. In what
amount of time and at what cost.
The can borrow student loans
which hopefully will be able to
pay off once they graduate.
They can work the research shows
that working more than fifteen
or twenty hours a week while
they're a full time student is
detrimental to their success. Or
they can come back on enrollment
which puts them at greater risk
of not completing.
So when I touch very briefly on
each of those issues.
In a joint effort with a cow
seats you disassociation we
recently found that the vast
majority of CSU graduates with
student loan debt. Came from
families with incomes of no
greater than fifty four thousand
dollars of income.
Nearly two thirds came from
families with incomes less than
twenty fab seven thousand
dollars.
Public data from the university
of California show very similar
trends.
About half of all bachelors
degree graduates with debt from
the UC had family incomes less
than fifty five thousand dollars
in the lowest income students
were three times as likely to
leave with that as the highest
income students. So this is a
critically important trend for
us to understand as we look
towards state policy solutions.
That to ensure that a college
education is affordable.
Students also worked to cover
college costs
I met all twenty seven of the
colleges that you just on that
map of California. The lowest
income students would have to
work more than twenty hours a
week to cover those costs.
At some colleges in all three of
the segments they would have to
work more than thirty hours a
week this is already went once
you've taken into account the
grantee that the billable.
So needing to spend this much
time working means less time
studying.
No more than any other single
topic that came up in our survey
of students students share how
these trade offs for their time
were holding them back
academically.
Moving forward to ensure that
the master plans promise of
educational opportunities
realized we need more and better
and.
It's in the basement
Julie.
We need at to bribe better
recognize and address the total
costs of college that students
are facing. And we must ensure
that financial aid investments
are targeted at the students for
whom college costs are the most
burdensome and for whom.
Barriers to enrollment
completion are most pronounced.
Currently the cal grant program
does that provide some support
for students for non tuition.
But hundreds of thousands of
eligible students every year are
turned away from the program
because
enough grants available.
A recent high school graduates
who apply for a cal grant me the
deadline that they're entitled
to a grants.
But if you're not a recent high
school graduate give to compete
in the most recent year see
sacrifice that over four hundred
thousand students competed for
less than twenty six thousand
grants.
Most of the students who are
turned away without a grant have
income so low that the federal
government estimates they cannot
afford to put a single dollar
towards our college.
Tions.
Never the applicants who do
receive a grant the portion of
the cal grants that covers non
tuition costs has not kept pace.
It's lost most of its
purchasing power you have the
award kept pace with inflation.
It today would be over worth
over six thousand five hundred
dollars.
Instead. The maximum award is
one thousand six hundred seventy
two.
Now in recent years the
legislature has created two new
financial aid programs to
increase this award for full
time community college students
in particular in this is very
important progress in the right
direction.
It is also very important
understand that only four
percent of California community
college students receive the cal
grant upon which these out on
grants are based.
So it's important games Gaines
for a very small group of
students.
So I'd like to close some by
sharing finance from one more
report that's relevant today to
today's conversation.
We recently interviewed twenty
two expert throughout the state
about their own perceptions of
the strains in challenges
related to college affordability
throughout how.
Among these experts there is
resounding consensus that
California has a college
affordability problem.
In all interviewees agreed that
improving college affordability
means focusing on covering non
tuition costs
students.
Many also expressed the
importance of doing more for the
neediest students including
nontraditional students under
service use community college
students former foster youth and
other first generation students.
Experts also recently are also
it universally agreed that
affordability challenges
negatively impact students in
several ways.
While student debt burdens rose
to the top meaning.
On affordable college means more
Sudan I'm almost equally
concerning to the experts were
the impacts of affordability
challenges on students
enrollment in college their
ability to get to college or
through college in a timely way.
In of course that it contributed
to equity gaps that we see in
college access and completion.
So within our current state
financial aid structure the
simplest way to make targeted
investments to address these
challenges is to increase the
number of cal grants available.
In increase the size of the
grants available to students for
non tuition costs.
But the experts we with whom we
spoke also underscored the need
for broader systemic reform.
That we need to also reduce the
complexity of the financial aid
system
we need to correct outdated
assumptions about who today's
students really are.
The legislative analyst's office
put out a proposal for
financially reform last year.
The California's you nay
commission is considering reform
options as we speak so these are
enormously important
conversations and we need to get
it rights.
AB implementing reforms will
work I will require both
political leadership and
additional investments
but the extent of the consensus
around the problem and its
implications.
Underscore the costs of inaction
thank you.
Thank you thank you so much W.
and I first of the chance to me
W. at a higher education
conference
so in California. And.
But you had a slight three here
really stuck with me.
And I've been repeating it in
Frawley bungling it.
When I've repeated the.
For the last couple months
which is eight for tuition
facilitates access.
But eight for non tuition costs
facilitates college success.
And and we're good is it if
we're setting students up to to
fail essentially what we're
letting them in but we're not
giving them.
What they need?
And the financial assistance
that they need so that they can
really focus on their studies.
And and be able to see it and
so I really love the way that
that was freezing really
appreciate that I won open of my
colleagues first doctor
Arambula.
Africa come visit you.
So I just wanted to recognize
two of the state's center
community college district
trustees who are here Miguel
audio Susan back as well as.
John the Allen just wanted to
thank you guys for being.
Thank you very much.
Senate Allen Jimmy Y.
disaffected just part of part of
the on the cal grant numbers you
disparate raised miss Crocker
and if you were talking about
how.
And can we four percent of all
students get the. The cal grant
be is it is.
Could use her flesh that out a
bit I mean I it. Presumably.
You're.
Keep his fuss about holiday
because I.
Recent budget things in my mind.
You. Have so.
So about four percent of
California community college.
They seek help.
Right arm what book but.
But but it's a chilly much
higher percentage get some form
of financial aid.
Yes about forty five percent of
students get the fee waiver will
we look at full time student
assembly almost seventy or
eighty percent of students get
a fee waiver.
And we get a federal help. For
the cal grant program is not not
closely aligned with the
community college who.
Students who are.
Going to community colleges are
off and I'm take
they have a gap between high
school enrollments.
College and college or if they
do go directly from high school
to college if often missed the
window maybe they didn't they
were not. College preparation
for.
Right.
So as part of your idea that we
ought to expand the.
Rules of eligibility.
For the government be.
Think I think we need to you
know we need to insure that more
of the four hundred thousand
applicants who are applying.
Not these recent.
It's have an opportunity.
On Thursday been different
legislative proposals for how to
that in recent years one is just
simply to increase the number of
grants available. Another option
would be to expand the
entitlement. For all college
grads are all high school
graduates are to.
To the few different ways to go
but the important thing is that
we go one of those ways.
And if it would you find what it
is that being the.
Close is equivalent to the cal
grant be.
For those students who are
coming into the cocky because
system a little later.
What would it would their major
sources of financial aid
typically for not eligible for
the? Government be.
Almost all as well the three
major sources of financial aid
the the three largest sources of
financially for California
community college students. Are
the federal Pell grants the the
fee waiver now known as the
promised.
And federal student loans
very few community college
students actually borrow federal
student loans but there is more
aid that goes to students
through the federal student loan
program. Them through the
Calgary.
And that the.
The fee waivers the Bob. Waiver
of heather okay.
Great okay thank you.
Thank you and I think that's a
good point you know. Caspian to
this whole effort which back in
nineteen sixty the vast majority
of our students were students
coming straight out of high
school.
And and today in two thousand
eighteen with so many more
students that are.
You know it worked for a couple
years and I than China.
A teen degree or.
You know start a family in are
coming back now that their.
Family situations more stable
whatever it is where the holes
that would set up don't apply to
them.
Then then so trying to find
more creative ways.
To make sure that we're
providing.
Financial aid and and support
the today's students as opposed
to the students of sixty years
ago.
Is gonna be a really important
conversation that we have.
So one quick question that I
have.
Maybe for Spencer you or I
their view is yes but from what
you've experienced so you seen.
What? Can you may talk about a
specific limitations of student
aid in covering some of the
students non tuition costs.
I think that you can run into if
any.
Yeah sure well.
The the first thing of course is
that when you have.
The pool of student navy your
granted from these various
source says.
The first thing it goes to
cover ease your tuition and fees
at university of course.
Then as a student my user
experience on this is that I get
sent the track or a check or a
direct deposit. In its for
whatever the differences.
So in between that night sort of
mention this my.
Having maxed out on the amount
of direct federal loans that I
can which Roth.
And.
That amount that I was awarded
time cal grant.
Dot still comes up short.
Even covering the three months
rent reporter that I would have
to pay.
So obviously that's your biggest
limitation it's that it's not.
Meeting the needs um no a of
students who are.
I finding themselves in in
housing markets like this that.
How I've server patchily rising
rents?
But of course.
On talk about you know that
leaves no money for.
Your basic needs costs that's
food.
Are you know basic toiletries.
It's your books.
Your equipment that you have to
buy.
For you loud. On your course
readers.
And.
I think it's I I really want to
put a.
In in what you said about.
The fact that something around
which to tweak combined those
two segments of students are
that would either drop the class
or try to get by in the class
without going it buying book.
That's a real the suit decision
that students make it certainly
decision that I've made
I usually err on the side of
just hoping I can skate by and
everything worked out.
But it does hinder my success
of course so. These things are
all interconnected.
Excellent since the dispenser.
NNW you've got or slide this is
our but the slide of the state
that shows.
Your college costs are for low
income students across
California and.
In the research that you've
done.
.
Where's my question is that I
want to ask.
Though he'd dot do not tuition
costs of college.
Del you seem to the very across
region of me are or something
Tyrone one region and lessen
another in. May is that should
be taken some flexibility into
account when we're designing the
programs.
Do you think.
I know that's a very it's a very
interesting question I think
actually gets back in some ways
to Spencer's through Spenser's
points around.
Cost estimates.
Whom he seemed we do this
research is often that it
doesn't vary as much as you
think
I'm the California sea nay
commission has for many years
now
put out.
Annual estimates of what the
non tuition because
college are so each college has
supporting their at a student
budget an estimate of what it.
They can either tuition to that
and then very there you have
your budget.
But it's a statewide estimates
most community colleges in the
state of California use that
state.
So that means Fresno City
College probably shows the same
housing that's.
As separate.
IBM's
college.
.
It's it's hard to imagine
housing costs are the same and
those two regions but at the
same time. Pulling together.
You know their own esta.
Can be time consuming.
Administratively.
So I think
issue nay commission's efforts
that there did working on right
now to get a better handle on
what's.
Actually are and how they might
the varying across
across in California incredibly
import.
Perfect thank you.
And I have a couple dozen other
questions I'd like ask bring
that same for the next two
panels.
So really one I think.
Spencer and Daddy for all your
comments today thank you very
much.
And so and it's been is going to
be the basic needs of students
food of mental health and
housing.
And and before I introduce the
panelists yeah earlier late last
year I was reading.
Occasions a we have a assembly
fellows program in the state
assembly where people were
coming straight out of college
can apply for when your
fellowship. In the state
legislature and I was reading
through these resumes and then
these applications of incredibly
impressive students and I was
shocked.
By how many students mentioned
that they started a food pantry
on campus.
And and the fact that. We have
a need for that many food
pantries on our public.
Hire. Education campuses in
California including I hear one
here Fresno City College.
And so our next panel is going
to be on basic needs of students
food of mental health and
housing.
And I want to first introduce
Maggie white who the student at
CSU Stanislaus medi.
Kim go on no whose of the
university of California basic
needs co chair A. you see
senators think him.
Doctor Denise Beverly director
of student wrongness and basic
needs initiative at California
State University office of the
chancellor.
And Colleen Ganley Thurmond.
Program specialist at the
California community college
chancellor's office thank you
all so much for participating
today.
And will kick off with Maggie.
Hi everybody good afternoon I
feel so privileged to be here
with you today my name is Maggie
Y. Democrat it's dean accents
last.
And the president of the cal
state student association
representing nearly half million
CSU students from Humboldt San
Diego.
And I gotta say like that
fantastic speaker from you see
who is just out here I was also
born and raised the valley just
couple hours of nineteen ninety
Modesto.
And you know I've been separate
what my position is present on
to travel all over the state
meeting wonderful people. But
Valley people are always my
favorites I am very happy to be
here.
I feel very safe I can say that
I hear a lot about the people
around me.
Separate the Friday before I
jump to my comment disliked
thank everyone here. For the day
that the divers work that you're
doing to support public higher
education in California and all
of your different capacities
whether to the legislature on
the university campus.
It truly the work that you do
have an effect on our on our
students and all systems I'm so
glad to be working on this idea
of.
I'm here today to address on the
topic of basic needs in higher
education.
But right into when I'm seeing
as a student leader and cal
state that Sam. I want to
acknowledge that these issues
are not unique to anyone system.
The needs of students to
identify affordable housing into
remain house throughout college.
To feed ourselves on a day to
day basis.
And to at least attempt to take
care mental health during the
rigors of our educate Dan.
Unfortunately not unique justice
Stevens I represent in the CSU
system.
And my position I had the great
privilege of working alongside
student leaders from all corners
of the state.
And the stories I hear on a
regular basis connected to basic
needs a truly heartbreaking.
I'd like to briefly touch on the
topic of privilege.
There is a great privilege and
being able to attend college.
And my case even work towards a
masters degree something that I
never imagined and I was a
senior in college and talking to
advise and I never been
something that. Was painted is
that they can be part of my
life.
We know of the many benefits of
that privilege.
Opportunities for upward social
mobility. Access to jobs in
industry in this great state.
That privilege of just be able
to pull yourself out a life of
poverty during own hard work and
determination.
This privilege is a great thing
but I think that this narrative
has in some ways. Hidden
disappears troubles of our
students.
I state leaders you almost often
care the struggle that your
constituents based on a regular
basis.
People who are chronically
homeless people who are sick and
disabled struggling to pay their
extremely expensive hospital
bills.
Single parent struggling to work
and take care for young
children.
School teachers working in
challenging classrooms not being
paid are supported enough.
These challenges are
overwhelming to the individuals
into the state. And sometimes
I'm sure it may seem that the
struggles of a college student
I'm not as great as those other
concerns.
However while there is great
privilege and healing a college
degree. The path to get there
can be as challenging as any.
And if the student lacks access
to their basic needs.
Food housing mental health
resources they have a larger
likely had of struggling in
college dropping out before
completion and leaving the
institution with that but no
degree.
With that being said I'd like to
break these issue at.
And address them one at a time.
But there's that student
security be heard for years
about the struggle that students
sometimes space to feed
themselves.
A few years ago this issue
became such a priority that we
began to see both a suit
associated students
organizations on campus since.
And even campus leadership like
that Fresno state.
Begin to address these issues by
opening food pantries on campus.
Since then many different
tactics have begun to utilize on
our campuses in the CSU. And you
get to hear about many of them I
am Sir at from doctor needs
badly at the director of student
while this the basic needs
initiative as well as other
representatives from the
systems.
Just a few weeks ago the CSU
released their system my basic
needs are part and the findings
were very Graham.
It was reported that nearly two
hundred thousand CSU students
face some form of food
insecurity.
Those numbers are staggering.
I think the assumption is that
the college experience should be
a struggle.
Everyone struggles in college so
I to this generation be any
different are we just too soft.
We just can't handle it.
I like to think that the
struggle we reference ought to
be. Connected academic records
of the program.
That mental and emotional
development that occurs when you
sit in a classroom surrounded by
diverge Spock an opinion on the
subject.
Not whether or not someone's
able to access officially
nutritious food to get
themselves through the day.
The impacts of the issue thirds
insecurity should be obvious.
But also should not go without
saying.
Students have trouble feeding
themselves apart having more
trouble in class.
This prayer is critical because
system wide and statewide there
continues to be a per she it
seems that finish line of
graduation even more quickly.
And while great work is being
done to achieve this goal higher
graduation rates. If we're not
addressing our students basic
needs the issue of food
insecurity is
obviously widespread. But it
cuts differently among different
student groups.
Los systemwide forty one point
six percent and CSU students
report some form of food
insecurity. Forty one point six
percent across the system.
Sixty five point nine percent of
black first generation college
students reported food
insecurity.
I'll say it again almost seventy
percent.
A black first generation
students in the CSU based and
security.
Among our students are
classified as underserved. Their
rates of food insecurity or mean
higher than the average.
This means that as we continue
to address this issue. The work
must be done intentionally and
with the state's dedication to
equity at the forefront.
And the to homelessness
unfortunately CSU students have
not remained unscathed. From
this state right affordable
housing crisis.
Before getting into what we know
about the CS use how much
students I want to tell a brief
story.
Last week very close to here
Fresno state.
CSA along with assembly members
coming era and Arambula.
Unveiled AB twenty seven eighty
four.
At delta pilot program to
address student homelessness.
For the president we want what's
Fresno state student leaders to
identify students what
experience homelessness.
To speak in support at the press
conference.
There student leaders tried for
weeks to find someone willing to
speak about their experiences at
public events. It became close
multiple times with multiple
students identified as homeless.
But no student out of many
identified were willing to come
forward and tell their story.
The stigma of homelessness
remains strong. And is no
different for our students.
And fortunately far too many of
our CSU students do experience
homelessness.
Ten point nine percent of
students system wide but fifty
two thousand students in the
CSU.
Reported being homeless sometime
within the last year.
And again our African American
first generation students
reported higher than average
numbers and eighteen percent.
I probably don't have to tell
you that when you're homeless.
Turning in that paper on time.
Attending class or office hours
and participating in high impact
practices and programs is
probably the very last thing on
your mind.
The issue of homelessness in
general and student homelessness
specifically. Remains such a
challenging issue debate because
they're so feel low cost
solutions.
Well with food and security
meeting the number of
advancements from partnerships
with county food banks to
donations from community members
to bring students to calabash
benefits.
Those types of low cost options
don't really exist when it comes
to providing a safe and stable
home environment.
Campus housing is not really a
solution from a students.
Because on many campuses the
prices near the local cost of
housing or may even be higher.
And in most cases there are not
many vacancies in campus housing
to serve best into the up
homeless throughout the
semester.
With few campus based solutions
available aye how much students
joined countless number and
other people who are homeless in
this state.
Praying for additional solutions
and resources to solve this
issue.
I do want to mention that we
have seen many campuses sat at
struggling with homelessness.
Many campuses have created small
amounts of emergency short term
housing to help shelter our
neediest students.
But for many reasons this is
merely a bandaid.
A good bandaid but a bandaid
nonetheless.
While we know that many college
age youth who are homeless seek
shelter for safety. And
emergency short term housing
solutions off our students at
least that temporary safety.
They're not proven methods to
keep that image was permanently
housed.
This takes us time last issue of
the portion mental health.
All of these issues seem to
relate to one another.
After all they're having trouble
finding housing it probably also
struggling to feed yourself.
And it experiencing homelessness
and our food insecurity you're
totally have troubles with your
mental health as you deal with
that daily trauma.
Of course there are other
factors that contribute to
mental health challenges to.
They. Of the college studies.
Their immigration status and the
national climate.
And the personal issues with
family friends romantic
partners.
These factors are all linked and
layered.
In addition cultural stigmas
make it a challenge to even come
forward. When one has a mental
health issue.
I've heard from CSU students at
southeast Asian background for
example who carries significant
cultural stickman. In seeking
help with respect their mental
health.
This type of statement only
compounds the issue of mental
health for the students.
And other to explain similar
issues in their communities and
households.
Stands up front tired for the
past two years to try to expand
mental health resources on
campuses but unfortunately we
have not been successful enough.
We know that the national
standard for mental health
counselors on the college campus
is one mental health counselor
per fifteen hundred students.
However only thirteen ever
twenty three campuses have
anything close to one hundred
that range.
At some campuses the radio is
much higher.
At Fresno state San Francisco
saying how stay LA.
The ratio is one counselor to
more than three thousand
students.
These ratios mean on many
campuses to deal with a lack of
mental health counselors
students report wait times up to
a month.
To see a counselor in person.
There's often a cap on their
visits throughout the year.
That means that if I go and I
put my name on the list they
call me in three or four weeks I
go see a counselor. And I make a
connection with this person I
finally filled I can open up and
speak about my difficulties.
That person have returned to me
and say I'm sorry I can only see
you six more times this year.
And I care for you to an outside
clinic.
If you can get the
transportation to get there
never insurance covers it.
That's unacceptable.
No student when they have found
the courage to come forward.
And acknowledge their mental
health issues.
Should have to wait so long.
About a lack of access the help
that they need to be safe and
successful on their campus.
Lastly on this topic on our
campuses student fees are being
used to pay for these mental
health resources.
This means that the most obvious
way to expand these needed
resources on campus is to
increase the if campus based
feels.
But this only compounds the
cycle of affordability in mental
health challenges.
Students are struggling with
food costs housing costs.
And rising tuition and fees.
If the only solution with
respect mental health is to
exacerbate another issue that is
not an acceptable solution.
I want to thank all of you for
allowing me to speak to you
today on this critical issue is.
I also want to thank the other
senior representatives who are
here.
Speaking today on the issues of
equity in student success on the
total cost of attendance.
All these issues are intertwined
and I feel so privileged to work
alongside you to represent all
California college students and
trying to solve these issues. In
partnership with our ski
institutional leaders think you
very much.
Thank you very much Maggie and.
Nagy mentioned that you know
maybe it's.
We just this younger generation
that's soft and can't presume
Maggie that you were born.
In nineteen ninety eight or
before. Alright so Maggie and I
are both members of the same
generation both members of the
millennial generation.
We've created millennial caucus
in the state legislature.
And for fear of offending most
the people in here of.
For the men on for the
millennial generation and and
the current generation of
college of of undergrad students
I'm forgetting the name of to
its current generation what
recovery because all.
Generation social media that's
we're gonna going. I know what
is it.
Senate generation Z. it it is
hard to get into college it's
harder to graduate in four five
years aye costs more to attend.
And and graduates are graduating
with more student debt.
Than ever before.
And so I I I die I can't you
put incredibly eloquently.
Really appreciate you doing
that.
Before we Bonta ten the alkaline
no I just want to.
Introduce my my colleague and
friend Jose Medina.
Summer Medina is chair of the
assembly.
Higher Education Committee and
is been working with me on the
the master plan.
The select committee on the
master plan for higher education
when I first approach Mr Medina
about this I said the I'll I'm
interested in compromising the
master plan that if it takes. I
just got elected if it takes ten
or twelve years that's how long
it's gonna take. A and Mr Medina
said I turn out in eight years
let's do a before that.
So is so we've.
You know.
I'd spend of the time frame a
little bit but missed Medina one
to give you a chance you once
introductory comments or.
Perfect.
Thought like introduced him
Delano Tim is.
The university of California
basic needs co chair at UC Santa
Cruz attempt by. Afternoon
everyone.
Yeah I'm the upper the
generation of technology that
I'm working on a.
The open.
Because there.
Using a map to the PC world as.
His new an ambitious.
But okay.
So thank you selectivity members
an attendee is.
It's an honor to participate in
this timely panel on hearing
assuring that the California
higher education master plan
meets the needs of students
across the state. Both two year
and four year public and
private.
I have my brief remarks will
contribute to your understanding
of the basic needs challenges
facing students today. As well
as what we're doing across the
university of California and our
partners to advance solutions.
So I myself have a communicable
as graduate I get CD UC Santa
Cruz I return to school after a
few years works thirty eight
hours and. No the Santa Barbara
cue muted thirty miles to school
so I I get a sense of this and
really appreciate this work and
I'm in it for the long haul
homeless when it as well as many
of us that go through our public
education system.
So I just want extend that eight
dollars to the university of
California at self as I begin to
really look at it as a system I
mean a comprises over two
hundred thirty thousand
students.
A hundred fifty academic
disciplines six hundred graduate
degree programs a ten campuses
serving undergraduates graduate
and professional students.
So has being data basic needs we
have to think about those three
student populations and how
we're developing and responding
to of all of their needs.
So a clear challenge in higher
education today is the impact
the cost of attendance we've
heard that from Spencer and
Debbie. As well so today's
expenses are other than tuition
they count for more than sixty
percent of the total cost of
attending a college and
university.
And over the last four decades
the cost of living for college
students has increased by over
eighty percent.
Peter I next senior research
economist of the federal reserve
best summed up the struggle for
students.
In relation to the number of
hours they need to work to cover
the cost of attendance.
So thirty five hours a week you
know compared is a few decades
ago is factored in that you can
succeed as a student and work
ten hours.
So we need to account for that
and think about how we're being
responsive to that change in
trend in it's alarming
implications.
So that means older generations
regular pay for much more than
lentils. As past wages now today
cover only one third of the cost
of attendance.
Further the institute because
success in.
That access is S. T. guests.
I noted in their work because
because for low income
Californians that it would take
up to thirty seven hours a week
at the high end for students.
To cover the cost of attendance
at the receive no financial aid
and had to cover all their
expenses by working.
So the increased cost of
attendance do affect student and
food and housing security.
Cordon the USDA food security is
measured by identifying food
secure.
Low in very low food security.
So low food security is a factor
of equality in very low's a
factor of quantities who just to
break that down for folks. And
food insecurity itself.
Is defined as a limited on
certain availability.
Actually adequate and see foods
with the ability to acquire such
foods in a socially acceptable
manner.
So the question sets in the U.
S. D. designed to assess. The
validity of food security are
eighteen tener six item question
sets that are used nationally.
So to start with understanding
family food security through
census data we find that
families across the U. S.. On
average are suffering fourteen
percent low in very low food
insecurity combined.
Soon look at studies in higher
education the results are
noticeably.
More significant.
So between two thousand nine and
two thousand sixteen there a
total of nine studies in the
problems of food insecurity in
college campuses.
With an average food insecurity
of loan very low totaling forty
eight percent.
So there's a signal right there
that there's something up I
guess you'd call Canary very
bright a Canary do tend to. And
on often security was assessed
in less than ten thousand
students
at that time which is very low
compared to the expected twenty
million college students.
Projected by the national center
for education statistics as a
fall twenty thousand fifteen.
So my colleagues who speak to a
broader national community
studies.
Con committee colleges from
hope lab at Temple University
shortly.
But I'm hoping that is giving
the context the national
landscape in the studies we can
then begin to look in the
California and what we're
learning here.
So with these challenges the
data points in mind the
university of California has
committed to drawing upon campus
and systemwide leadership.
To advance upstream approach to
addressing student basic needs.
So through president Apollo Tana
those national global food
initiative launched in twenty
thirteen revert to line existing
student support services and
programs within a food access
and basic needs framework.
I initial efforts sought to
reach the skill of needed to
develop and implement and assess
intervention is to address
student food insecurity. As well
as begin to better understand
the housing and homelessness
dimensions of basic needs for
students.
So from twenty fifteen to twenty
eighteen we've senator efforts
across research.
Prevention and support. Advocacy
collaboration an overall
sustainability which I'll speak
to you all today.
So the university of California
begin examining the issue of
food insecurity and twenty
fifteen starting with the
student food access and security
survey.
Funded by president apartado is
part of the global food
initiative effort.
To increase the response rate we
use the national college
assessment survey that is
already set to be administered
on for UC campuses.
And the remaining six campuses
the UC institutional research
and academic planning division
administered what we call the
got food survey.
These two surveys were
administered online in spring
twenty fifteen to a random
sample of more than sixty six
thousand students.
Across ten campuses.
Of those asked a participe eight
eight eighty nine hundred thirty
two undergraduate students and
graduate students responded.
And as you can see our initial
finding it found that forty two
percent of students who are low
in very low food insecure.
I miss other key findings that
can be reviewed in the survey
results.
Share the member is an online
hopefully with the materials
from the session.
From that the university of
California's food security study
inform the decision to revise
our institutional assessment
measures.
So these measures include the UC
undergrad experience survey the
graduate wellbeing survey the
undergraduate cost of attendance
as well as a graduate cost of
attendance survey.
So with that a twenty sixteen
twenty seventeen was oppressive
year for search advancement on
our basic needs efforts.
By improving and expanding the
cost of attendance survey for
undergraduates.
And launching for the first time
ever costs of attend
survey.
In addition for quality of
studies about.
Basic.
He did.
The Berkeley you.
Go UC Davis.
IDC LA.
CNN Greg experience survey team
and the graduate well being.
Survey team also.
Thirteen homelessness
it's into their surveys.
Upon this larger interest and
attention to the issue.
Attempting to be respond.
To help our efforts be more
specific with the data
in the research to inform who
are best serving. And so it was
Reyes around particular
demographic identities combined
have increased.
Neither food security housing a
security homelessness so that
level three data as part of the
results on that we don't time to
speak about today but it does
inform how we're. Serving the
most at risk populations is a
priority in our solutions.
So forty four percent of
undergraduate and in twenty six
percent project students
reported having experienced food
insecurity.
Which is in line with their
twenty fifteen findings of forty
eight and twenty five percent
respectively so what we do those
questions as we brought from
eighty nine hundred students to
over sixty six thousand
students.
Which serves the database for
undergraduate graduate students
to research an informant engage
this really timely issue basic
needs.
So are prevention and support in
twenty fifteen twenty fourteen
twenty fifteen effort access and
basic needs subcommittee
initiated campus level working
group's to better assess student
needs.
How are campus level as well as
to inform system wide efforts?
In recognizing there's a growing
concern around student food
security president Paul Tano
allocated seventy five thousand
per campus to address the
immediate challenges of ensuring
student access to nutritious
food.
While my self makocha room
Kaneto from UC Berkeley
developed a multi year strategic
plan with our campus leadership.
The NPI study of twenty fifteen
and formed efforts to improve
our data collection as discussed
earlier. Across institutional
student surveys activating
central leadership in providing
the capacity to better assess
high risk student populations
based on campus level specific
data.
And further the president
committed additional three point
three million over two years
through twenty sixteen twenty
eighteen divide emergency
assistance financial aid and
food literacy and life skills
training.
In a strength in the impact of
food access and basic needs
working group's efforts on each
campus.
The food access and security
basic needs subcommittee
sponsored by GFI and overseen by
you see office of student
affairs establish these working
groups on each campus.
Nay could acquittal
representation from
undergraduate graduate students
staff faculty
a community partners because
again it does take a village
power point or basic needs.
Led by our chief I co chairs our
food access NBC the working
groups have been working closely
together to address the
challenges and develop
implementation plans.
To specifically address the
unique needs of each respective
campus.
So over the last two years we've
made significant headway on our
food access and basic needs
efforts.
And this includes hosting
semiannual system why basic
needs meetings.
Facility monthly system wide
leadership causing quarterly
professional development
webinars.
To better respond and engage our
students and successful
solutions.
Releasing a Stanford access and
security tool kit I campus level
of security interventions.
Establishing a basic needs
outcome impact evaluation
reporting system with timelines
the campus efforts.
Providing over twenty two
thousand students with direct
basic need services a supporting
campus.
Launching central online
websites a communication
resources for basic needs at all
UC campuses.
I'm already a seventy four basic
needs resource centers with
several more campus is going
online by fall twenty eighteen
so there multiservice centers
for financially literacy.
Advising and resources technical
assistance in choice piece
pantry selections.
Engaging CDSS and comforts
awareness in a rowing eight
thousand students in California.
Can we recently released the UC
food and housing security
reported December twenty
seventeen. To provide more
detail to what I'm sharing.
I'm just very briefly on one
additional support just looking
at the aid the UC provides our
students complemented by cal
grant in the federal aid. We're
trying to provide the best
packages for students and even
that you've heard the data of
what our students are struggling
and so I'd really and
compassionate connect with the
struggles of our sister sectors.
In our students there in.
Our every seeing collaboration
really has extended across
informing legislative policy we
really appreciate the state's
investment in concern.
Our national engagement as we've
traveled over thirty for
conferences and meetings to
build a network of higher
education aware of the
possibilities to change the
struggles of our students and
make solutions possible for all.
And strengthen the partnership's
across CDSS are food banks are
homeless you services at our
sister sectors. Which I have to
give credit to it's so exciting
to be on a panel with Colleen
into these. A we've had
strategic engagement to really
think about what we can do
across our sectors of the
response of. In the three areas
are developing a basic he's
vision together and higher at.
Building a proactive come
communication engagement system
which can help inform pending
policy and other elements that
come up. As well as sharing
institutional research and
analysis to ensure that were.
Better asking the questions in
one form how we help our
students succeed from one system
to the next.
In going forward you see our
model really is to flip the
pantry at the bottom. That's a
crisis resolution are proactive
work these to go before they
come to college whether it's at
a communicative stated you see.
Our early outreach programs need
to understand basic needs
financially literacy how to
understand housing rental
markets and what independence
means the student as you come
into your own. Sense of identity
and growth in the university
system. And then work on the
campus level resources which we
are practically doing sewer
working herself up
the pyramid into law it will be
launched in the next phase of
our work is the president called
for a basic needs master plan.
For the university of
California.
So just in closing I'd like to
thank the committee and
attendees and our partners.
In the university of California
stands at the state the CSU
system the committee called
system to comprehensively combat
basic needs challenges that
affect our students and families
statewide. And we look for to
provide any additional materials
freeze in resources to inform
the port work of this committee.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much Jim.
And now like to introduce
doctor Denise Beverly a director
student wellness and basic needs
initiative at the California
State University. Office of the
chancellor.
While you're pulling this about
all joke so we have interns in
the district office in our
assembly office their high
school students.
And they were teaching me how
to use Snapchat.
And and we joke that don't
teach me how to use Snapchat
I'll teach them how to use a
desktop. Hinton.
.
So.
Look that already we are perfect
alright couldn't.
Good afternoon my name is Denise
babbling.
And I'm Tom some of us that.
And I am the director of
student wellness and basic needs
initiatives for the CSU.
Thank you for this opportunity
to share some work that's being
done across our twenty three
campuses to help students who
experience challenges with basic
needs. Particularly food and
housing and security.
Food in housing in security
impacts many California college
students.
Just as it affects countless
communities across the nation.
A recently released national
study found that forty eight
percent of student respondents
reported food insecurity within
the previous thirty days. And
those of those sixty four
percent also in support it
experiencing some level of
housing and security.
And twenty fifteen the CSU
commission of phase one snapshot
study of a small student
population that found that
approximately. One in five
students experienced food
insecurity while one in twelve
experience housing insecurity.
We recently completed phase two.
A more robust first of a kind
of its kind study out released
in February twenty eighteen
which confirmed my much of the
data from the snapshot study.
I know most everyone here is
probably somewhat familiar with
the California State University
at many of you have friends and
family.
Who have likely it?
Graduated from the CSU but in
grief across our twenty three
campuses we have almost half a
million students.
Who comprise of the most
ethnically economically and
academically diverse student
body and the nation
more than half of our CSU
students our students of color?
One in three are the first in
their families to go to college.
And fifty two percent of
undergraduates are recipients of
the Pell grant.
The CSU the powerful engine of
social mobility.
Providing students an
opportunity to earn a high value
degree and into the workforce
prepared for the future.
Our commitment to CSU students
and the academic and future
success.
Necessitates a commitment to
supporting their basic needs.
When students basic needs are
not addressed it can have an
impact on both their personal
and academic growth.
Impeding their ability to
achieve their goals and earned a
degree.
That is why and student well
being is a priority in our
graduation initiative twenty
twenty five.
The CS is planned to ensure that
all students have the
opportunity to be successful and
graduate in a timely manner.
Positively impacting their
future and producing additional
graduates to power California's
economy and innovation.
The results from the snapshot
study work to action for the
CSU.
That we must do more to help our
students who need it the most.
And I am proud to say that that
call was. Answered across the
CSU.
I campuses have been hard at
work linking students to
resources services and programs.
That address students security
housing displacement and
homelessness and financial
crisis.
For students struggling with
food insecurity all twenty three
of our campuses at either a food
pantry or a food distribution
program.
All campuses provide cal fresh
application assistance to
eligible students so that they
might have healthy eating
options.
And a majority of our campuses
offer meals through meal sharing
and meal voucher programs for
example.
Fresno state offers a
comprehensive food security
program that includes an on
campus food pantry a meal
sharing program cal fresh out
reach an application assistance
and a campus garden. That
provides students with access to
fresh fruits and vegetables
additionally Fresno was one of
the first campus in the nation
to develop an app that alert
students to available food
that's left over from on campus
events.
Preventing foodways and
providing an opportunity for
students to receive free food.
Since you campus is also provide
students with short term
emergency housing.
More than two thirds of our
campuses offer on campus
emergency housing or vouchers
for off campus housing.
For example I CSU Chico staff
provide students facing
emergency house.
Facing emergency housing crisis
hotel vouchers to provide short
term relief and the campus will
serve as a co signer on lease
agreements
to help students transition into
long term housing.
Similarly Northridge will
provide funding for security
deposits to help students and
need of procuring housing.
In addition CSU campuses also
provide financial assistance to
students in need. More than
eighty percent of CSU students
receive some form of non loan
aid.
But beyond federal state
instructional financial aid
programs the majority of our
campuses also offer fight on
emergency grants and funds.
For example San Jose state
offers emergency grants for
students that they are not
required to repay.
Sacramento state also offers
emergency grants and host
financial literacy workshops to
teach students about money
management and budgeting.
And many of our campus have
targeted fund raising campaigns
aimed at raising funds for basic
needs resources for example at
CSU eight East Bay. The campus
and associated students work
together to establish a campaign
to solicit donations
from the community and support
of students basic needs.
And the first year alone more
than a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars. In donations
were secure as well as eighteen
hundred over eighteen hundred
mil swipe donations. Nineteen
hundred donated items and forty
five hundred dollars in
emergency aid.
These are just a few examples of
program services and outreach
that exist across the CSU.
System wide we are implementing
the CSU basic needs initiative
to coordinate services across
campuses helping them reach all
students in need of support.
Initiate negative is structured
around five areas.
The first of the dressing
addressing the immediate needs
of students.
The second growing campus based.
Campus based basic needs
services so they can reach a
decent additional serve our
students.
The third scaling best practices
from one campus to across the
system.
The fourth working with partners
in collaborating. And the fifth
is ensuring long term
sustainability a basic need
services.
And February.
Just last month we had are
system wide basic needs
initiative conference which by
together close to three hundred
attendees. To share current best
practices learn from national
experts and develop action plans
for further program development
to address students basic needs.
Assembly woman Weber provide a
powerful inspiring words
challenging us to continue
working toward eradicating
student hunger.
And homelessness on our campuses
and throughout the country.
And on that note I'd like to
also thank you and legislative
colleagues for your support of
our efforts
the two point five million
dollars recently allocated. To
all three of the higher ed
systems in California for Senate
bill eighty five. Has been very
helpful in the CSU those dollars
are being distributed to all
twenty three campuses to help
them be designated as hunger
free.
These funds are critical in
helping campuses develop
implement and enhanced resources
related to food insecurity and
housing display set.
We are proud the vision our
campuses have taken to address
these concerns head on and
continue to support their
efforts from the chances office.
We also know that there is much
more to be done. And look for to
with our local state and federal
legislative allies to help us
ensure that all students are
able to have the opportunity to
be six.
Thank you.
Thank you doctor billion and
doctor belly mentioned doctor
Weber.
Who's coming over from San
Diego is also on other select
committee for the master plan
she was able to be here today
but he's been very gates
throughout the whole process.
And I'd like to introduce
Colleen Gimli EMR man.
Program specialist for the
California community college
chancellor's office
I killings.
Thank you thank you for having
us.
I'm shorter senator. So I am
hopeful that. A little bit lower
thank you.
Thank you to the committee for
allowing us to come and share
some information with you. On my
name is Colleen Ganley Ammerman
and I'm with the community
college chancellor's office in
my work buckets include food.
Housing. Mental health self
foster youth homelessness out.
For our students so. It's AB fab
pretty tall charge but I'm very
excited that our office.
Pacific we hired someone to work
on these issues.
I'm first.
.
Time that I'm aware of that
there's been someone designated
to work on these issues.
So a little bit about our system
we are seventy two districts a
hundred and fourteen colleges
and we serve two point three
million students.
And I think it is noteworthy
that out of that total student
population two thirds are
considered part time students.
Meaning they're taking less
than twelve units and these
students are often adult working
adults students.
I their parenting students.
Their students that are working
multiple jobs to make ends meet.
And we also have a
demographically very diverse
student body.
I in two thousand seventeen our
board of governors.
Adopted formally adopted a new
vision for success.
For our system. Listed on this
slide are the metrics
that are driving that new vision
for success I won't go into
great detail but I have provided
a link.
About each of these metrics and
the time frames established for
this new vision for success.
Bob. And I want to shift to talk
a little bit about basic need
data that we know nationally and
at the state level.
We.
So nationally of the Wisconsin
hope lab conducted a survey in
two thousand seventeen.
That survey included seventy
community colleges across the
country.
We had fourteen California
community colleges participate
in that survey. And the data
shows that two and three
community college students
report being food and chick
insecure fifty percent report
being housing insecure and
thirteen. To fourteen percent
report being homeless.
And while we do not have
statewide data that reflects the
community college student body
one of our larger districts Los
Angeles community college
district who participated in the
Wisconsin hope lab. Up pulled
Ste almost six thousand of their
students as almost sixty three
percent report being food
insecure fifty five percent
reporting housing insecure. And
a whopping almost nineteen
percent of the students in the
Los Angeles community college
district report being homeless
which to me is quite staggering.
Especially given the fact that
generally speaking we don't have
housing resources in the
community college system.
We have eleven districts that
offer housing resources a. On
campus dorms.
So this this.
A rise in awareness about these
issues.
Is a call to action for our
office and also for the others
segments. I'm we conducted a
basic needs survey across our
campuses asking faculty staff
and administrators what kind of
resources were available to
college students to help meet
their basic needs.
We have. A hundred and five
responses two hundred and thirty
nine individual respondents.
And this is what they told us
about food pantries a sixty
eight percent reported having
food pantries on campus.
Sixty almost sixty two percent
reported having support for cow
freshen Roman on campus.
And almost sixty one percent
reported other available food
resources including meal
vouchers grocery gift cards
farming farmers market products.
And so you might ask how are we
funding these efforts there.
Generally speaking there are
not designated resources to
address the basic needs for
community college students.
Unfortunately for us and as
Denise alluded to we got to a
half million dollars of one time
funds.
On for food security activities
on our campuses we also received
a one time apportionment for a
foreign half million dollars for
mental health services.
And I'll talk a little bit more
toward the end of my
presentation about what we're
doing around mental health
services.
But I want to jump into the
hunger free campus activities.
These funds were allocated to
support that either creating or
expanding your campus paid food.
Campus based food pantries. And
also ensuring that students have
information about how fresh but
fits I'm all of the community
colleges that are willing to
facilitate these two activities
are eligible to get these funds.
In preparation for this work
our office of hosted eleven
regional cow freshen Roman
training.
Trainings across the state we
had eighty to community
colleges.
Faculty staff and administrators
to these trainings we reached
over five hundred with a day
long training with the goal of.
Training faculty and staff
about the application process
and what are the barriers
students typically experience.
.
The demand was overwhelming we
would like to additional
trainings but there was such a
hunger across our system. From
faculty staff and administrators
to understand what are the
barriers that students are
experiencing when applying for
cal French because it's not just
as direct as.
Filling out an application
there's multiple steps and
there's bond lots of things that
the students need to do to
actually access the benefits.
I'm we are also offering
technical assistance to the
colleges and we are. Connecting.
Cao for staff at the county
level with colleges we are
connecting local food banks with
the colleges.
We have joined our sister
segments on an inter segmental
up policy research work group
and we've also assembled a small
nimble and mighty. Aye internal
workgroup with leadership from
the system and from the
community colleges themselves to
work on these issues.
We work with external partners
including the department of
social services you STA.
We have a blossoming
relationship with CSU Chico on
I'm getting some federal
reimbursement for cal fresh
outreach activities on campus
and that's new to our system.
Some were very excited be
hosting our first ever basic
need summit.
It's going to be in Sacramento
on April twenty six and twenty
seven.
And so I wanna switch back a
little bit and talk about mental
health services and what we're
doing in that effort. And I
would say when I was listening
to the folks talk about the
ratio of mental health
providers.
To student. Us stood numbers.
Who generally speaking we have
maybe one two or three
practitioners at the outer most?
To serve thirty forty fifty
thousand students stone there is
a real need I think the
legislature.
I recognize that and included
some funding some one time
funding.
But we have very very limited
resources to support many many
students who have.
S. and depression anxiety thank
you.
.
So we had for a half million
dollars now we facilitate a
request for application process
were in the process of approving
those.
Now.
The goals of that are to.
Provide direct services to train
faculty and staff and to help
colleges get connected with
their county governments I'm
sorry the county behavioral
health.
There's a few statewide.
System resources that our
office is sponsoring we have ag
a suicide prevention gatekeeper
training them that we've had.
Available to the community
colleges for about six years.
We've got I'm there's three
student facing modules and three
faculty staff facing modules. To
date we've trained almost
seventy thousand people.
We are.
Collaborating with an
organization a national
organization called the crisis
text line. Home where they
provide tax base mental health
services we created tool kits
and hopefully any community
college that you go to. You will
see these incredible posters and
business cards and that key
change in. The any kind of
collateral material to let
students know about the service
it's a free service.
And so far we have just under
two thousand students who have
access this service we're very
proud of the relationship with
crisis text line. And then
finally we are working with our
health services association and
our online education initiative
and we're developing student
facing modules in canvas which
is our online education
platform.
And this is just a small sample
of the topics so why student
logs into their canvas account.
And what there is to get their
grades or whether it's to get.
Any of the materials and or to
even access our classes. Out
they will see a list of about
twenty five or thirty.
Modules that really that delve
into all of the things.
That could be impeding their
academic progress so those are.
Absent system wide resources
that we're very proud of home
given the limitations on what we
have to work with.
So there's my contact
information thank you very much
for the opportunity to speak
with you and thank you to the
students.
I'm it it takes a lot of courage
to come up and talk in front of
this group.
Great.
Thank you very much Colleen.
And with a look at open my
colleagues for any questions or
comments about how.
Doctor metal. Church.
I would feel remiss not to
humble brag a little bit about
Fresno state and the work that
Mary Castro of our First Lady
has done.
It shows the true need that we
have within our Valley and it
reminds me of a quote from says
search office.
That he finds it ironic that we
pick fruits and vegetables to
fill others table to such
abundance.
And yet have so little left for
ourselves.
Growing up here in the Central
Valley in the breadbasket of the
world it's.
Truly a shame.
That our Fresno state students
have such great need.
In the past eighteen months
alone they've used that food
pantry fifty thousand times.
And it shows we as a state have
a responsibility to try to help
out.
As the budget sub chair of
subcommittee one I oversee the
cal fresh.
Department and wanted to ask a
question about that if I could.
I wanted took follow up and
understand if there were
specific improvements on
functionality. Could we help to
improve. This government service
and make it more accessible for
our students and if we can
follow up after the fact and
have specific recommendations
and ideas. On how to do that I'd
like to. There is a bipartisan
group right now that are working
to make improvements with and
cal fresh both to increase
benefits.
But also to make it work better
for communities.
So with that I just wanted to
say thank you for your testimony
and.
And appreciate what you brought
today.
Thank you doctor regular.
Senate Allen well I just wanna
first of all appreciate the
extraordinary work that has been
described to me it you know.
You know with with limited
resources.
Seems like all three the systems
are stepping up and trying their
best to you to figure out ways
to address some of these you
know pretty unnerving challenges
that exist.
With our students and and you
know there's certainly a lot of
work to be done and and a lot of
gaps in the
estimates were very ably
described by. Her to student
speakers out but but I I am I'm
glad to see that systems
stepping up and taking this
issue very seriously. I will say
yeah I've seen ninety white.
.
As. I'm sure that you get to me
she's coming testified a couple
times both the their house of
the budget sub.
And.
I'm certainly hoping that. By
the time I turn out of the
Senate I will see her in the
legislature. Because she really
has been a tremendous student
leader both at the board level
and also I'm as president Acosta
conference states dudes
association and I.
I.
I think you have office and. I
think you get any so I hope to
hope to see you join us
and I wanted to ask Mr.
Gallagher no I'm just one quick
question about the food security
data a when you mention that
forty two percent of the
California you see students are.
Food insecure. There's another
line in your side that says
child history food security is a
twenty three percent is that to
mean. That. I'm.
That twenty three percent of the
students in the UC system.
Experience three in security
before they got college when
they were when their kid.
Correct in that it's and it's
beyond that so it's not just
limited resource students that
come from all different sectors
they may choose to. Have a same
gender partner the family rights
them off or you have a different
life decision that then cuts
them off of him fast for their
still dependent.
I'm the lower finding is that
they're all forms of insecurity
that just not does not directly
correlated child food security.
And so we have a lot more data
and with eight minutes I could
only share so much. So could
have been effectively. So you
are you. So that this part of
the point you're making here is
that.
That out of those you see of the
other students who are food
insecure.
.
You note nearly half of a for
nearly half of its is actually
relatively new experience I
think yes yeah I heard. In the
both very difficult things to
have gone through for sure but
and and and both going to
present their own challenges.
That's correct.
And in the idea is that.
.
That.
You know the user that there for
the that the folks who were not
food secure but now are when
they get
school. That you know because
the basic their parents of kind
of said Hey you're eighteen now
you're off in college you're
taking care yourself and they
don't have the resources to.
Correct the other struggles real
for them and.
The free college basic needs
literacy is nonexistent we don't
have the capacity currently kid
to twelve prepare students.
So that they have no inclination
of where to go or what to do was
our first you know commitment
was to get the communication.
Centralize the resources and.
Let students know that we're
here for them.
Okay I appreciate that that's
very interesting.
Then you Mister Allen.
It.
.
I is one question I had one
comment that one question one
comment is.
I really appreciated.
You know folks are talking
about. Mental health needs.
And and I've been focusing are
presented
a district and some communities
of really struggled with you've
mental health issues.
And we focus a lot on high
school students and junior high
school students.
But it but as I think about it
we with it too.
Youth suicide cluster the past
eight years.
And in both of those who is
also some recent graduates of
high school.
Ends and so college students
and so we're gonna and work with
my staff to figure out if we can
integrate.
De the higher education systems
into some the work that we've
been doing.
And the work they were doing
this year.
.
If.
You can give them what they.
A bunch of you are really all
you you know I had that certain
recommendations are or alluded
to problems and and I can guess
what the recommendations would
be but. If you just give us one
or two recommendations of either
changes to the master plan or
things that the legislature can
do. To address.
The issues that you're either
facing personally as students or
seeing as administrators on
campus what would those be.
Thank you so much that question
I really appreciate that.
And and you know there's there's
twenty floating around my brain
very.
Alternative very quickly
to.
Amulets doctor badly was it
three million that the systems.
Receive just recently five is
two point five million
I think having earmarked funds
and for our schools around
mental health counselling. And
it can't be for every single
campus particularly in my case
was yes he's missed ten campuses
that don't have. That ratio gap
the one fifteen hundred I'm I'm
looking at those Fresno state
house LA San Francisco state.
And looking at those schools and
trying to it as a very first at
getting those ratios from one
counselor to three thousand more
students to at least one to
fifteen hundred. I think that
makes a real difference. I think
the campus says that have
already done an amazing job
advertising those services been
they get overwhelmed we don't
have the resources to back at.
And I think this generation what
something that's amazing about
assets or myself in there.
Were a lot more willing to talk
about our problems.
And maybe that's due to social
media we feel that we can really
put things out there and see
how.
But if we get to that point we
were seeking help and were in a
way rejected.
I think that has long lasting
consequences for the individual
law.
And so making sure that the
campus says can have their
sources to back up those
promises a basic needs and
particularly and.
For mental health counselors on
those impacted campus says.
And frankly I I know that
there's been a lot of attention
to. To the food pantries on to
become says I keep referencing
Fresno state factually meet we
just as of last week. And I had
a chance to tour the food pantry
and it was.
Fantastic I know they're going
to use some of that money that
that was just received recently.
To put an more refrigeration
units.
More shelving work more produce.
And I walked in and I saw
students.
So freely using it without
embarrassed and or anything like
that just.
Shopping through the aisles for
for produce for bread.
I would love to see that scale
on every single campus
but if you have a chance against
absolutely fantastic it's just
committee that his one people
who runs it. Along with did
marry Castro. And just absolute
dedication everything from the
campus.
To make this something that
isn't stigmatize isn't all.
You can go any time and I was
going to question your means
testing of do you really dead.
I know that campus based banking
the legislature can do a lot to
encourage that and define the in
a sustainable way seven keep
that going first.
You're much. Noticed briefly
share think adding basic needs
the master plan with clear
metrics that work within the
interstate all sector and the
legislature so that we can
evaluate the measure report and
work together.
Really exciting and I think
really timely for this
generation of work because of
the scope of the problem.
There's mental health in this
food housing security you don't
know which one will show first
of how to support a student. But
we need to align the resources
and think about the dotted lines
to really connect in between
those services. In our system
so.
On the second element would be
considering the types of policy
that can intercept across these
SP five is great for the housing
or the food specifically. We
brought housing that we've
connected mental health so to be
exciting to see what kind of
path for be have.
With that as well so thank you
for asking that question extent.
I agree with.
Everyone spoken so far I would
say to adds that is definitely
the Caltrans.
Program an opening that up so
that there is.
.
Less red tape and hoops for
students to have to jump
through.
Specifically the twenty hour
work week rule is it's tough for
a lot of students.
Especially those who are and
medical.
Have medical.
At medical school or having to
do internships or things like
that they're not able to work
those twenty hours so. They're
they're you know there's a lot
of red tape around that I'm the
only thing I would add is.
Maybe some legislation around
affordable housing around
campuses.
And even with some of our
campuses and in and around
campus is doing new construction
maybe having something in the
contract that speaks to.
Providing affordable housing
units for students.
Matter hereby campuses.
The Germans.
There's.
I think that.
Sustaining the allegations that
have been made to the systems
for food security is something
that would be very useful and we
see an incredible growth across
the community college system.
Updates of colleges really
putting together robust food
pantries.
I would also see that the.
.
Now how service act fund and
this is sort of a one off but
it.
Mental health services is
really an issue for our students
and for our system.
I think I know there's
currently a bill that.
Speaks to using mental health
service act funds for in higher
education I think that
certainly.
Worth.
Investigating further and
supporting. Them the department
of health care services also has
a project that has primarily
been targeted to K. twelve
students for many years.
Called local education agency
and it is a program that allows
the K. twelve system to bill
medi cal.
For mental health and physical
health services were working
with the department health care
services but I'm not sure if it
could possibly take a number of
years to get.
The regulations modified.
To allow community colleges
that was a bill that allowed
community colleges back in two
thousand fifteen. To begin up
filling the LA a medi cal
billing program. But there some
regulatory up barriers to making
that happen and we currently
have.
All fifteen community colleges
that are interested to start
billing and.
We have some regulatory
barriers to be able to do that.
Thank you.
I wouldn't love to follow up if
I could on the mental health
services act.
Have quite a bit of questions
about that as well as the
commission and.
Just want to make sure it's
working for our communities.
It's just good governance for us
to look at.
In particular looking at cal
fresh there is an opportunity
this year I'm going to be
working with another assembly
member on try
figure out how to streamline.
The application and make it work
better for so would love to
follow up on both of those
ideas.
Thank you Sanam doing the I want
to buy mentioned executive a lot
higher and people here. Today
and I am a.
You knew we had we had a little
bit of a chat about this at the
used roundtable and present the
Poltava came.
I know you brought up the issue
of of for a housing your
campuses and of course one of
things we're looking at even in
the context of today's
discussion is that they're just
very different.
Communities
where we have campuses manner
some.
Where that the housing? Where
that the land costs the
development costs are are
relatively well least by
California standards?
And then you got places like I
la Vista that was mentioned
before by UC Santa Barbara the
in the area around Westwood
UCLA.
Yeah Berkeley and it there just
just out of control costs that
are really really tough and I
was just really struck by the
students comments about having a
pac twelve people into a two
bedroom. Apartment is
unbelievable.
I'm. Like the old tenants of.
The Laurie side. I.
But when they I should mention
is it did in those communities.
It is proven to be very
difficult for ride variety of
reasons to do development.
And.
And you know that's really
something that the that the
legislature's looking at.
.
But the campuses themselves in
the foot three key systems and
actually have a lot of
discretion was are a lot more
discretion.
A lot more power over the land
use decisions the construction
decisions on their own camps is
it enough feel that way. When
you've gone through. The.
The headaches of trying to
build and additional student
housing on campus.
.
Because of all the pressures you
get from the neighborhood and
the community but but you know
as a matter of law the campuses
have a lot more power to do what
they want on their.
Land
then any other type of
developer.
And.
.
So you know as hard as it may
feel to do that sort of
development it's harder do a.
Sometimes off campus and I think
I really courage the campuses to
be bald and and.
And
in assessing and addressing.
Their housing needs.
You know on their own land I
will sell I just the other day I
was out. Of the van the
brilliance of Berkeley the
chancellor Berkeley keen on the
Los Angeles to talk about what
was happening as person actually
ask a question about student
housing.
Cost because it has become such
a big problem and
the chancellor announced them
they're going to be doing a lot
of work.
Pushing forward with
student housing on various plots
of land that they have around.
And the Berkeley campus.
And and I I was just I was glad
to see that their barreling
ahead on this.
If there other campuses you
wanna have conversations with
them I would be happy to
facilitate.
Because they're there you do
have sovereign powers as as a
public our institutions of
higher education.
And then I could you to utilize
those powers.
Good point thank you very much
please.
Join me in in thinking the
panelists.
In the last panel will be a
panel on ensure ensuring equity
in student
excess.
And I'm like to introduce our
Han drew lamellae
student at Long Beach
college.
Manuel John to can't to student
at Fresno Pacific university.
As well as Michelle. That I see
Siqueiros seat Seguros Seguros
Seguros.
President of the campaign for
college opportunity.
And Benjamin Duran Duran.
During that return.
Duran.
Honestly.
Executive director Central
Valley higher education
consortium I got are the first.
Not in my.
Something goes. Gonna. As born
Texas.
So thank you very much and we'll
get started.
The with all hunger.
Great thank you.
So is there is a generation gap
they live off my computers like
cater on everywhere at that.
I'm gonna just go over this if
that's okay.
No that's perfectly fine
calling your colleague of racial
to stay up there for it.
LA or has given.
So hello everyone I'm aims all a
hundred million I am a student
along which should be college.
Else have the privilege of
serving as vice president the.
Statewide soon organization
disincentive California commune
colleges and where an
organization that represents.
The over two point three
million since across our system.
Seek Intel la a membership of
about thirty members not quite
equitable in regards to see
membership we try our best to
put the concerns of all of our
students in various demographic
groups.
I think it's a little of myself.
I can tell you are you know
when I first decided to return
back.
To.
School after may your half
break I I would never have
imagined I still still being
here four years later.
I can tell you that I never
would imagine myself having to
jump out of several classes ID
two conflicting work schedules
as well as.
You know.
.
Don't think through three part
time jobs at a time and in doing
that now continuously try to
balance that on a daily basis.
And I never would have match
myself maybe justice matters
specifically having to drop a
communication sixty class three
separate times because those
counted on me.
De to just conflicting
schedules and class
cancellations and.
I most certainly would never
thought four years from now
earlier that I would be here at
Fresno City call speaking to you
all. About some issues in
regards to soon equity in
academic success.
I'm so this should be a it's a
surprise to some of you but the
time would you colleges being a
two year institution is no
longer.
The case.
You know.
Glazer Frazier how the chance
office is that sixty seven
percent of students actually
graduate or receive their any
type of degree within two years.
In fact the practice of
students taking longer than two
years is so embedded into our
system that a lot of our data
Ste track students and six your
cohorts. Not giving up enough
I'm to be reactionary and really
giving us a sense of what we
imagine Camino college students
to be right six year students.
.
So bingo myself ring from allow
American background I sometimes
he was so caught between two
worlds right. Semi Hispanic
culture we value education at
any level but for many reasons a
lot of our lot of my people do
not complete or even attempt any
type of higher education a lot
you know it's not.
How my mother and father never
had the opportunity to attend
high school let alone a middle
school?
They're busy immigrating over
and joining immediately into the
work force to fight for
themselves and their family that
was to come.
And whenever I valley's Mexican
so visits and heroes asking how
schools going in for the most
part exotic and spending any
time at all in my higher
education journey.
.
We also value the commitment to
hard work.
Adult thing that thought has
ever occurred so I Perrance I
would never be able to not work
while attending college. There's
never that's never occurred to
them whether my sister graduated
from you see your seats you.
That you can only commit to
school they have the mentality
that you can you have to work
while attending college in
that's a lot of the culture that
we come from right. We have to
have a commitment.
.
On the contrary so friends of
different a brings up the
question how my decisions to
take a year off for my decision
Steven work while attending
college right. They bring up the
question about what ifs what if
I decided to go into university
which had the option to do from
three at a high school. On the
opposite suggestions that maybe
should stop working as much or
even all together. Or they ask
me don't take any breaks in
between are just push through.
And as much as I'd like to see
how my tener five year plan is.
Like already implant mapped out
is the reality is that things
don't work out the way I planned
them to things to work out for
students with the plan
themselves to do as well.
And yes it shows the focusing on
my education if I really truly
wish to be successful maybe I'm
spending too much time working
maybe I'm spending too much
trying to trying to earn some
money and not focusing on my
degree. But there should be some
form of balance a balance
ratchet still be able to fill my
cultural and work
responsibilities while attending
school.
And they will be able to
complete those within two and
three years I am.
So what's holding students back.
Is it the remediation are basic
skills that sets students up
immediately in a position where
they have no other option but to
finish a sequence of course that
can easily take two or three
years just to even reach
transfer level.
Is it course offerings and
scraps in class scheduling that
are unpredictable and sometimes
offer zero suggestions for
students to move for from any
type of sequence.
Is that the cultural piece that
sometimes isn't translated
correctly when speaking to a
counselor who may not look like
me. Or know about the future
plans in my expected thousand
I'll use.
Is the lack of financial aid
resources to support attending a
college that requires a one
hundred fifty dollars textbook
that my professors wrote
themselves I'd know the option
of buying it for my individual
tech a. Cold bookstore.
Is it the misrepresented sticker
price of college that attending
university doesn't accurately
represent the cost of
attendance.
Is it even more widespread of
conversation we had earlier that
students have such a minimal
resource that they're suffering
from food and housing in
security. And such unstable
livings condition that it's
affecting their performance.
The answer improving student
equity and academic success
around a cabs isn't just fixing
a simple issue are placing
reactive proposals. You know
just our media education alone.
From a report that's right for
the legislative analyst's office
to some of our. Members here in
March.
You're three quarters of first
time Camino college students are
determines unprepared.
More than forty percent of CSU
students are determined as
unprepared. And twenty percent
of those first time you see
students are also declared is
impaired.
So from the onset we are you
know alone in Marin and
maneuvering through an almost
archaic website to fill a
confusing application questions.
We wait in lines for possible
times only to be told you have
to come back in two three weeks
to meet with a counselor. The
has a one to seven hundred seat
a ratio.
We hope that our financial aid
if awarded is dispersed early
enough to have our books by the
second week of class.
All and managing to balance the
successful work family and you
know some of us have a social
life.
So institutions will tell you
that they'll be the first to
tell you that they're doing
everything they can to improve
the idea of academic success of
students but even if the tools
are there
we need to do a better job
assistance at those tools.
Really are there and where to
find them.
So there been out if I can offer
some suggestions on how we can
move forward in specifics
incommunicado ge's you know I
I've been involved the committee
because system for a few years
now and I've been of involved a
lot of conversations and. Most
recently has been a conversation
that's kind of.
.
You know was a little weird to
me and it's it's a conversation
on moving towards this idea of a
fifteen unit Tory more of a full
time.
Unit load for students right
fifteen units per semester
making it a thirty units a year
total and I know there's a.
Individuals argue that you know
fifteen units are doing its will
get students there faster.
.
But I would argue that students
of knowledge in the full time
status now will not will not be
incentivize by. At an extra
increase in financial aid to
push them through right. Let's
say give a scenario of a single
mother I working.
She's taking nine units right
now barely making them and I'm
not even qualify for full time.
And additional grant of two or
three thousand dollars isn't
gonna keep her from child taking
care of those family values. And
that's a look at the reality we
face for a lot of our students
now. You know we talked about
earlier and and you know Devon
talking made a great point that
a lot of our students are
returning students and. Is a
huge number of data surrounding
the and I consider myself
retiring soon and I only took a
year and a half off. To students
to come back five ten years
later don't even have. This
ability or even the generational
skills sometimes even knew over
there are systems.
And.
If you move forward toward the
system of you know providing
more resources to individuals of
full time status of more than
twelve units are fifteen units.
I really urge you all to this to
talk the reality that might be
displacing some questions now.
Beautifully thing that
displacing of students that are
even eligible for full time
status now in even further of
writing this a resources to
competitors across our system.
Another suggestion I would hope.
Would be to write an additional
focus on maybe I'd idea of
course scheduling class
offerings. In the realities I
faces a communicative students
when I first enrolled.
I didn't know what classes are
going to be offered at you know
a semester ahead of time and
that's a really lot Communicorp
students face. And assist you
that and you see my pillow
different we can map out a two
year plan.
But I've never understood how we
expect students to maneuver
system within two years when
administrators and faculty
leaders can never even planned
out of your head in the course
scheduling.
You know when you have a chance
to.
You know center over account
isn't colleges do more what
we're planning to count their
the class offerings. Nam
sometimes we look at class
offerings were it not really
focusing on begins I'm for
dividend graphic groups are work
groups in regards to evening and
weekend classes. And no surprise
when I visit you see issues you
campus and I go there in the
evening and there such. You know
is a popular student life and
it's driving in this its is so
encouraging to see that people
are wanting around the evenings
when I visit local community
colleges and there's no one
passed by PM. You know offices
are closed sometimes we extend
hours the first or second week
of class but for the students
who cannot get those
appointments within that that
first time period. Are left to
work on themselves and work from
home and try to figure out you
know on minor maneuver whatever
system they have set a plate.
And. If we want to continue our
conversations in regards through
mediation yeah I'm hoping to
have a meaningful conversation
around that we also need to be
open to the idea casa mixed
expectations I not be on par
with the reality of some
students academic levels.
So the conversations relying on
you know on placement test is
that students levels is also
changing right. Mortal measures
have come to the forefront
deciding we believe students
ready we most successful.
Things like high school GPA
previous workload or even a
thirty minute counts or visit
can have just as enormous affect
on whether I had to take two
semesters of map before reaching
a transfer level. Where they
have to take? Against you keep
me from being enrolled in
another required class but
whatever idea placement isn't
you know entirely after. An
assessment test can be seen as a
way for two seconds scores for
students expected. Achievement
levels because we use the tool
to assist faculty in providing
an adaptive courts and adaptive
working environment for
students.
Faculty can finally learn some
for my data to students who test
intercourse and a bit dot the
courses to more realistic level
person success.
This information copy made
available using high school
transit bit especially for those
who don't self report.
An assessment to my not be the
answers to our questions
surrounding placement and
remediation but it can be argued
that we need more compatible
data to go about creating
adjusting reflect the courses
instead of using outdated
metrics that may negatively
impact some of our students.
So we hope to continue like on
successes of passed bills like
assembly bill seven of five who
was also forming even greater
data sharing relationship with a
key to talk partners. If
remediation such an issue you
know where there's a start is it
at the key to twelve level are
we not preparing them from
segment to segment. Center board
data can only get so far and
would sometimes no way of
verifying that information
without some validation
procedures. They'll be some and
I pay place since along the way.
And hope although these
partnerships may only benefit
those populations coming
straight out of high school. A
huge portion of our students to
come out at system we must
encourage their students as
well.
The conversations are on equity
instance success on singular
issues since success is directly
related issue discussed earlier
like college affordability and
basic needs. There's no doubt
that these issues of affect our
students differently some more
than others but if you plan to
move forward toward relevant
vision for twenty first higher
education system. In this
consent it continue to ensure
that these and.
This plan meets the needs of
all of our students whether they
be working adults single mothers
straight outta high school. You
know different ethnic groups
image keep that in mind if you
plan to move forward towards a
better future.
Okay.
Thank you very much alone
Euronext it will have mean well
John can to.
Hello everybody think for.
Hearings held today and then
you committee.
It's refreshing to see that you
guys are act to see some like a
committee actually hearing SO
near soon you can get lost in.
The today's stuff sorts
affirming a guest.
And so money was menu can to I'm
I am academic journey starts a
small rule city club foreign.
My farm is city that is over
ninety percent spending.
And in cemex most ruled smaller
or cities and sell can Valley my
farm is home to many long come
in immigrant families.
And as a result of the low
income area the school district
of should not receive from the
same funding as other. Property
to the public taxes most.
Some areas surrounding fund.
This means the fund had
facilities and programs that
sometime some might consider sub
par.
So it is very easy for someone
to look at McFarland perceived
as a density.
And to be honest that's
something I did for so long.
I looked up and fund and I
thought. And what in
appreciation time finally
matured. And I start to
recognize my success in college
thus far.
Until I finally. It wouldn't
taste.
Sorry Canaris.
That's.
That's a good music.
But longtime insurance start to
recognize mixed success in
because that's part and started
preaching the role models around
me. I realize what Fong was a
great place.
I like despite depend inequity
McFarland to find myself reading
and encouraged to succeed higher
education.
I was prepared because I was
better the gray pants and a
great family. Acknowledge them
because they are the real reason
for my success.
My grandparents emigrated from
Mexico but the bus had a program
that hopes of living the
American dream. There of course
face many hardships.
And but they managed to instill
the idea of grit and
determination to my parents.
As a result of their efforts
both my parents would eventually
graduate from college and my
father also continue to receive
master's degree and become a
school administrator.
So the stages are had already
been set for me to be more
likely to succeed.
I did not know that.
I was always looking at my
environment and comparing it to
other places in thinking
McFarlane wasn't good enough.
My junior college in Bakersfield
wasn't good enough.
And finally anti.
I'm not sure to make you into
for the Pacific university they
realize that those all those
things were good enough.
I'd.
I realized that my parents were
a product of small towns and
farmland I thought supportive
all the teachers that I. That I
looked up to a part of the same
type of smart spending
communities.
All faculty members also part of
small communities.
Also despite the low funding in
our schools many teachers up to
put extra hours to.
For cadre news programs like
added writing workshops for
public personal statements
mother look back and see the
value in going up in McFarland.
Promoted to look like me
surround me and lead me to
believe that anything could be
possible.
My experience in higher
education has been quite
different.
Then high school of course the
financial burden of college
pushed into spend a few years at
local communicative ge.
Going up all the oldest and then
you realize. That your parents
at the finance for others
students in college you can of
the but bullet and a. Start off
at a community college.
But.
Although the colleges different
took awhile for me to just my
parents were always by my side.
My parents wouldn't mind me to
visit my cancer every week
because he to be proactive my
transferring.
My parents are my me don't
believe to director time
opposite between all those
classes they remind me. That and
and the degree would be worth
all the effort. Out of venture
transferred to prison Pacific
within two years of for the five
units.
Since I didn't fully listen to
my parents about being proactive
my courses it would come back to
haunt me. Got a bunch of. Five
years instead of four.
But I have no regrets I'm happy
with my progress. The be the
good thing about the minor
mistake.
Is that my brother would
eventually transferred to you
for the Pacific university.
And then try to state and be on
the right track to graduate.
Immediately.
So I was happy I was here from
the percent Pacific university I
saw that. He was the home*
side continued Pullman knows
down hit the books and get the
grades I need.
And so if I can relate my story
to the broader student
population. I would encourage
students to try and find hope in
their minor minor but no matter
what it is.
Look for all models that we're
power you to do your best I
wished I was a cookie cutter
solution I could offer you a
punch in the dry direction of
several model.
The process you deserve process
you have to discover for
yourself
a to my parents another teacher
for granted not until use them.
For. As a research again the
fearsome become more active in
Texas that success so. I think
this is also true that
universities can provide and
help.
Fix equity in our communities.
I visit the city university all
the plan about many things that
can help improve equity instant
success.
I would come is because of what
I call repair mentor.
Is my favorite job on campus and
I think it's a great step in the
right direction to improve
equity.
As a multicultural peer mentor I
am one of the six to stressors
as a role model friend. Or
mentor to help people their
first generation college
students navigate through higher
education.
But opponents fund by the US
program to advance Medina
academic success and the good
thing about is that we for
surfers generation college
students so any first generation
students. Contention to be a
part of our program.
First generations and third
generation cautions cannot be
Lassen universe things
university since I don't have
that family member who basic
shell before them and higher
education. There ought to not
real friend is the right
decision for them.
Parents often don't do not their
parents not often understand the
challenges. That their children
may face insular Zemin tango but
grow between parent and child.
First generation soon sometimes
do not know how to manage our
time outside of a high school
setting.
These two three all prioritize
work over staying to help out
their family's financial
burdens.
Students under duck out also
sometimes fear for applying to
government programs in general.
It can be very scary for
students be experiencing these
troubles and realize that their
parents cannot help them despite
all their efforts.
This can be very discouraging
for students so is our job to
bridge the gap. For these tunes
and be that role model to help
them stay on most.
Stay on the path and most.
At image.
To help them.
To give them more wild role
models that are wiser.
And that look like them.
We will be the first ones who
you keep all those tunes as best
we can.
So University should provide
students with dub twenty to ten
different social awareness
program to be part of different
scholarship programs and
interact with people on a
different social spheres.
University to be able to
encourage leaders to be aware
and Chile represent their
student body.
I believe students benefit the
most when their mentors
<c.green> can</c>
relate to that doesn't mean I
have to be some of the same
race.
But the leadership be competent
and consider enough to hear
their situations.
And.
Students should know that their
pine self and they should not be
unjustly help of success hard
work should be only Kate only
thing the gauges success.
Last if you come from.
If you come from home place you
that your band showcase your
ability to overcome adversity
and rice a challenge.
That is a vital skill set that
you get the police have if
you're a person that comes from
an equity and succeeds did your.
Did your but do your best to
become a role model to other
people. I do inspiration for
many people who I didn't even
know.
Every colleges acceptance letter
that I heard about.
From an upperclassman was a
great inspiration to me every
time I heard that someone
transferred to university in two
three years does a great
inspiration to me.
Every time I heard about some
can you tell that right after
college thousand inspiration to
me and they may never have even
known.
So.
So you can sure you can't by
people. By own personal success
and the test when you can share
slash shared trend of generation
of success.
Abby that starts at the
university level by applying
great leaders.
Great points thank you man well.
I next that we have Michelle
sekeras president of the
campaign for college
opportunity.
Thank you. Thank you didn't.
Good afternoon now.
Chair Berman and members of the
committee and everyone here
thank you for inviting me to
participate in this hearing more
importantly thank you for having
the hearing it for the work that
you're doing.
I am I just wanted a state for
the record I also was not around
in the nineteen sixties.
Although my daughter does say
that I'm ancient and on my last
birthday ask me how that felt.
My name's Michelle cicadas I'm
president of the campaign for
college opportunity. And I used
to always say that.
I was super lucky that I got to
college.
You see my mother I immigrated
here from Mexico with only a
sixth grade education.
I she had no idea how to help me
fill out that faster which all
of you should know is due
tomorrow if you want to be
eligible for cal grant aid tell
everyone you know.
Tell every undocumented student
that they can still access the
dream act.
So I used to say that I was
lucky that I was able to fill
out that Pfaff said that I was.
Encouraged to apply to college
that I ended up going to Pitzer
and then to UCLA on affirmative
action scholarship.
And then I got out of college
with about sixteen thousand
dollars and dad.
I out which was pretty fantastic
at that time given the world
class education I gotta both
institute
tions.
But now I tell everybody that
it's absolutely not at all
related to lock.
In fact it's related to
everything that you can make
happen and that you do S.
policymakers.
Because it was policymakers that
insured there was financial aid
so I could go to college.
That there were student loans so
that I could afford to get there
and get through.
I and it was those affirmative
action.
Supports that allowed me to go
to graduate school and be the
first in my family to or not
only a bachelor's degree but a
master's degree.
The campaign for college up to
ninety was founded by folks that
were around in the nineteen
sixties.
In fact David wolf and Steve
Winer were baby boomers that got
to benefit from the master plan
promise.
Got to go to you see for free.
Are if you can imagine. And were
dismayed in the early two
thousands that our state leaders
were not funding higher
education sufficiently to make
sure that students could have.
That promise that we've all
talked about.
So they founded the campaign for
college opportunity.
And our focus and mission has
not changed since two thousand
and four and that's that more
Californian should have the
opportunity to go to college.
That once they get there they
should actually complete college
and that we should be unabashed
unapologetic about closing the
racial and ethnic gaps that
persist in California higher
education.
I'm much has changed since we
started at the campaign for
college opportunity fourteen
years ago.
We've done a lot more to grow
access in California but not
enough to close the projected
one point seven million.
Shortfall of graduates that we
are going to need.
In some ways the good news is
more and more Californians are
ready to go to college want to
go to college. Have completed
the a through G. requirements so
that they can get to college.
And yet we continue to turn
away eligible students at the UC
and the CSU. Every single day
including today because we don't
funds are universities enough
to.
Take them all.
In nineteen ninety five about
thirty five percent of high
school graduates completed a
through G. those are the courses
that you need.
To get to college.
Today aye that number has
increased significantly to a
record forty four percent.
But there's huge inequality when
you breakdown that figure by
race
in fact white students completed
a through G. by forty almost
fifty percent but Latino
students only thirty five
percent of high school seniors
who graduate that are like the
you know can even apply to you
Sierra CSU. And only thirty
three percent of black students
can apply to use your CSU.
That's unacceptable.
The other thing that's honored
that unacceptable or the
enrollment cap set by the master
plan.
We've said that only the top
third of Californians should go
to you Sierra CSU campus.
That worked for the nineteen
sixties but not for today when
more and more jobs require that
students actually have a college
education.
So. My ask to you as that you
left the enrollment caps at the
UC in the CSU. It should not be
harder for our kids to get into
college than it was for us.
Especially since this economy
practically requires a college
education.
The limits of the master plan
enrollment caps and inadequate
funding for CSU and you see
forced many students to attend
community college first with the
hopes of transferring. To
complete a bachelor's degree.
Unfortunately the route from
community colleges to four year
universities is much more of a
Mayes than a straight forward
passed away as you already heard
from our to student leaders
here.
Although a majority of community
college students in roll. Out
with the goal of transferring
only four percent.
Only four percent do so within
two years.
And only thirty eight percent
after six years.
Transfer students will take six
point four years to earn a
bachelor's degree at the UC. And
seven years at the CSU.
That results in an additional
thirty six to thirty thousand
dollars in expenses for transfer
students compared to freshmen
admits.
The transfer process is broken
in California due to the lack of
coordination between the
segments.
California's also unique in its
lack of a statewide official or
entity that insurers are various
segments have to work together.
More seamlessly.
Such an entity must have the
responsibility authority
capacity staff and financial.
A resources to be effective in
advancing a state agenda.
For California not an agenda for
the UC. Not an agenda for the
CSU not an agenda for community
colleges.
An agenda for California and its
students.
That agenda should be to
increase college access
attainment rates to improve
transfer and close the equity
gaps.
We need an entity that keeps the
interest of students on the
state at the center of any
conversation between the
segments.
The C. S. you in the UC offer
their own version of admission
guarantees and two different
sets of lower division general
ed requirements first transfer
students.
In twenty ten as you know the
campaign for college opportunity
sponsored legislation to
establish the associate degrees
for transfer. Which offer
seamless one hundred twenty unit
passed a bachelors degree.
Students earning this associate
degree for transfer guaranteed
admission to the C. S. you with
junior standing. And a bachelors
degree with for ways to
guarantee that they won't have
to complete more than sixty
units.
There are now eighty tease in
thirty two majors with college
is still developing these
programs and we're starting to
see the impact.
I just want to share one
statistic students that transfer
to a CSU with an associate
degree. Actually earned that
bachelor's degree forty eight
percent faster that students
that transfer the traditional
way.
They earn it out of twenty seven
percent rate.
There are a lot of efforts to
expand the ADT program and we
support them including those
efforts to align with the
western governors us university.
And also with historically black
colleges and universities
across the state.
But we need to make sure that we
continue to maintain that
promise and expanded everywhere.
Are there other means through
which we fail to design colleges
for student success it's often
lamented that many students are
not college ready when stepping
onto campus.
But we must also be Frank and
asking if colleges consistently
prove themselves to be student
ready.
Alejandro already talked about
remedial education so I'm not
going to go into that. But we
also sponsored assembly bill
seven oh five to ensure that
colleges could use more than
just the assessment test.
To place students by one of your
colleagues Jacqui Irwin.
I'm. Guided pathways is also
another means to shape college
practices to make sure that more
students get to their goals and
reach their dreams.
As previously mentioned most
students come man with the goal
of transferring and yet there
Matt with a lot of confusion.
Last year we actively supported
the state budget investment of a
hundred and fifty million budget
allocation to expand guided
pathways in community colleges.
And.
You know it's called guided
pathways but it simply common
sense.
Students should arrive in
college and not have to gas how
they might pull off transfer or
get a certificate or degree.
On March fifth a. We are going
to release left out how
exclusion in California's
colleges and universities.
Hurts our values our students
and our economy.
This report analyzes the
leadership faculty academic
Senate diversity by race and
gender of our community
colleges.
And universities.
While that next students now
composed forty three percent of
our undergrads and black
students another six percent of
a room in California. Only
twelve percent of faculty
members across our colleges and
universities are Latin at.
Only five percent are black.
Leadership roles are still
highly exclusive with whites
comprising sixty percent of
senior leadership roles in
higher education.
More than sixty percent of our
faculty over seventy percent of
campus academic Senate's.
And over eighty percent of the
systemwide academic senates
across our community colleges
and universities are white.
As leaders who care about
improving student outcomes and
closing racial gaps in it
inequality in our own state.
Let we share that there is no
way to do that without ensuring
greater inclusivity in our
campuses.
You heard from both our students
Manuel and I'll handle about the
importance of seeing themselves
in the leaders in front of them.
All students
white black Latin next Asian
American. Benefit from being
exposed to the diversity that
has made California strong.
As policymakers I urge you to
require community colleges and
universities to collect and
report data by race of their
leaders and academic Senate's.
They're only required to do it
for faculty and students that's.
Not not.
We're all urged governor and the
Senate. Many.
To. See region.
See.
Please. Anchor college governor.
Refer the population diversity
of California.
And.
Of the number of women in our
state.
I just want to share a few stats
that you'll get to see on
Tuesday.
The UC regents has twenty six
members only seven women.
Sixty two percent are white.
The CSU board of trustees.
Thirty five percent women.
Seventy percent white.
The community college board of
governors.
Forty one percent women.
Seventy seven percent white.
We are the sixth largest economy
in the world we're not gonna
maintain that standing or that
force. If we leave people out if
we don't close the racial gaps
that persist and if we don't.
Just talk about how progressive
we are as a Californians but act
on it.
The California dream is premised
on the idea that any of us can
imagine and create a brighter
future.
Well only honor the dream by
ensuring our children can
partake in the same
opportunities.
That past generations were able
to.
You started this hearing by
talking about the promise.
Promise as a noun means a
commitment to do something.
I urge you to use it as a verb.
Which means you will do
something.
Thank you.
Thank you very much Michelle
and and next
been during an exam
director Central Valley hired.
Consortium.
Thank you.
Okay ó whole life trying to
find this worse for them.
The.
Other.
I'm trying to shut it out Choi.
So it was all were different in
this.
I was around in the sixties aye
Nguyen. I remember the sixties.
Great time hit hit hit hit.
Number all over that for those
of them who reap with for the
part of the six if you can
remember.
Shop from the Central Valley
higher education consortium and
I came today. Ought to talk to
you about equity and about
student success
and when we talk about equity.
And ski and wood shop arrow my
going to do.
Up when I start talking about
equity and student success what
we're talking about is truly.
Are.
The fact the third but the two
are married. Have a good friend
of mine who says everybody is
everybody.
All is all.
We don't do cold porch we don't
so so much tell you about what
we're doing in the Central
Valley.
The Central Valley who are weeks
of the Central Valley is a is a
group of of colleges and
universities all from Stockton
all the way down to of Kern
county from some walking calmly.
Down the Kern county which
fourteen community colleges.
For community college district
offices.
The three California state
universities in the in the
region. It includes the
university of California the
tenth floor campus of the camp
of the of the system and that
concludes five of our
independent colleges and
universities.
In the valley.
So we come together to single
voice and it's a unique
organization in that in that our
board of directors of the
president's and the and the
chances. Of the institutions so
that we get when we come
together.
We come together we strive
speak with one voice up what you
look at what we have listed here
when I have listed here. Are a
number of partners that were for
we've been partnering with here
in the Central Valley to bring
student success and equity
because we think. That you have
to be equally given the equal
and inclusive then it's got to
be student success across the
board right it can't just be
some other so the sunlight up.
Because I'm mindful of the time
also so but.
Back in twenty sixteen.
Our board of directors for the
directors had a had a some in
fact up in fact assemblyman.
Arambula was there any like all
fired up because we were showing
data we were showing data that
was very very specific. About
what we needed to do as as
colleges and universities and
Central Valley to lift all of
our youngsters.
Again equity to bring them all
up and so there are there are a
number of things set that came
out of that summit that I wanted
to talk about so the first
strategy. The first strategy
that we're doing across the
board we're trying to scale this
thing up across the board is a
co requisite remediation. End up
with color called correct with a
real patient different folks
college different things but
tell you what it is in the
second.
That's correct with the
remediation and mathematics and
English.
What we know?
What we know is that when young
people?
Get stuck at the gateway at the
community colleges we have this
this huge group of students.
Who get to the gateway to
transfer and never do?
Ninety two percent of them never
transfer because they can't get
past college algebra the
couldn't get past that great and
in time is a problem. Because if
you're in the community because
of just state of another here
another year and a half two
years. Them start losing folks
there's a study from the public
policy institute of California.
That tells us that in it when
they studied the Inland Empire
Los Angeles and the Central
Valley. That in a five year
period.
Now get this.
So for this support for the for
the legislators on my couch we
spent all that money and we
really didn't get anywhere.
Three hundred thousand students.
Got to the gateway.
And that were crossed into
transfer.
That was an a five year period
for just those threes those
three years of of California she
can imagine. What's going on in
the rest of the state so that
it's an equity right medicine
benefit right that isn't okay
four four X. number students to
get there and not be able to get
into the. Promised land do not
be able to get to get the to
cross that to cross over.
So our colleges and universities
are implementing cho requisite
remediation on hunter spoke to
the bed. And and.
And and about this notion about
Hey how do we place students of.
The assembly passed AB seven
forty spend referenced a number
of times today. Awe and then and
then chancer Tim why.
Did this really gutsy thing and
he signed an executive order.
Requiring multiple measures also
at the California State
University
system so now in the California
State University system. And in
the community colleges there is
a quick requirement for placing
students and these gateway
courses.
Using multiple measures
but but as a result of that ins
and that CSU they're also be
required to implement co
requisite we.
And the community colleges are
moving along here in the valley
we have a movement where these
colleges are taking call
represent remediation at scaling
that up. And what that means is
that just very simply for those
of you don't understand it so
let's take English one a.
So those of you who were a lot
smarter than me would've taken
English one. And taken a three
uniclass bang that out and gone
through.
For those people that were not
as well prepared you would take
it and probably didn't passed.
Or you or worse yet no worship
worship you would get in there
you take a placement exam and
they would tell you because it's
a. Are your three levels below
college ready so that means you
have to take semester one
semester to semester three.
Before you even got into English
one a which was no guarantee
that you're going to pass
English when I.
We go on and on and on you can
see that you can see the
quagmire right.
With co requisite remediation
you're placed.
Along with the other folks in
English when a but instead of
whoever died and said you can on
you know you'll have take
English. Three hours a week.
There are some of us who need
five hours a week right so there
there may be that the regular
three English three hours of
English actor taking with
everyone else. And the
additional two hours might be
spent.
Might be spent on to it onto
Tauriel on as an additional
assistance to make sure that you
get through because the course
that you're taking has the exact
same rigor. Has excel set
require the same requirements
as the other folks who got
placed in there. So when we when
we look at the data that's what
when assemblyman Arambula when
you look at the things about why
are we doing this well. And and
what's true right so what work
so we are trying to scale that
appear in the Central Valley so
that when young people get into
college.
Given to the community colleges
the third ever take or the CSU
now that they literally are able
to get through the gate we
courses and then get on get on a
with life. So that's that's one
of the things that we're doing
here in the Central Valley the
other one is fifty to finish
such as that.
I under spoke to it and and he
said you know.
There are some folks who can't
do it and that's true what we
don't want to do it you don't
want to diminish those folks.
Who can't attend school time I'm
a school full time there are
folks who can't go to school
full time we understand that?
But we also understand I think
Debbie Cochran mentioned when
you look at the research the
research says.
Students who are going to school
full time.
By completing and the clean
completing faster.
Time is a horrible but can you
imagine if we could get kids
risk through through university
through the communicative
university in four four and a
half years five years Max.
Versus seven or eight.
Can you much of the savings to
the state of California that we
could direct to other things
that we do so well our our
recommendation is that we one of
the recommendations would be.
Are giving back to the co
requisite remediation that since
it's now becoming a part of
what's what what is transforming
the colleges is that. We really
look at a professional learning
and opportunities for folks as
we as we. Are are faculties are
being asked to change the very
way they do what they do. Off
after having done things one way
for a long time and it'll take
awhile to two one.
To implement these things so we
look at fifteen to finish what
we're trying to get young people
to not only up.
Get full to get their financial
aid and you've heard all about
minutes allowing you to that.
Get all the financial aid get
the benefits from that from both
services the county another sort
of things. To give you the
opportunity to attend full time
if you possibly if you possibly
can are others are other
strategies that would be a
recommendation is that the
legislature seriously to take a
look. At a LA longitudinal data
sharing platform.
That would allow us to share
clout a data from the other que
que arcade twelve partners to
the community college to see if
you can the CSU. Right now their
individual their individual
cycles that exist out there and
it doesn't make any sense to us
and it's difficult for us to get
that data if we can follow kid.
From from the six grade through
the high school into the
community college. And and
literally have the parents also
following by by the way by have
the parents follow have the
students follow we can do that
there are there are there it's
out there it's simply a matter.
Of of doing that.
And then the other strategies
egg and you've heard the other
efforts to to guided pathways.
So we're implementing guided
pathways across across the
valley all of our colleges and
universities including our our
CSU do you see where all and are
independent of France. All are
are all picking up the the
guided pathways because I think
all I think senator of senator
Alben spoke about the wraparound
services.
But the university of California
kids get.
Which is wonderful but again
everybody is everybody in all
it's all.
So it's not good for you see
kids why isn't a good for like
other kids right so with with
what the four pillars with the
four pillars of. Of book of love
of guided pathways so one
doesn't take.
The not caring getting through
and get in them and it didn't
take into other hunter spoke
about. Going through these these
horrible website and tried to so
of getting kids to and the other
thing that's what you've got no
man has to get up to select a
path I'm Amanda major. A
direction in which they're going
to go the other one and then
another pillars to literally
literally give them the
intrinsic student services we
heard about one two three
thousand of its counselor.
Student ratio twenty fifteen
hundred to really literally put
some services to some dollars
fifty for like recommendations
up. Up with respect to retrieve
sixteen services to make sure
that the students. At the
community colleges. For instance
are getting both her parents for
Mrs that the kids at the
university of California and
then the other is the one I was
talking about awhile ago. Which
is the wrapped the up the
professional learning to make
sure that learning this taking
place and that faculty are given
an opportunity for professional
learning. Do you know I used ice
to be a K. twelve god I suggest
you pretended by school district
before I went to the
communicative. I used to more
professional development and
training with my K. twelve
teachers.
They're not our community
college folks ever got.
Does it make any sense.
So I mean work so anyway.
That's what we are that's what
we're doing here in the Central
Valley and we're doing it
because we believe first I
missed Medina.
Thank you.
Mister chair so I am assembly
member Jose Medina. I represent.
Another part of the in that part
of the state of California. I
represent the Inland Empire
riverside Moreno valley and the
city of Paris.
Similar to the area where we are
right now we have a very low.
College going rate.
I think that with the Central
Valley the Inland Empire the
Lois college going rate in the
state of California.
I was around in the sixties.
Matter of fact in nineteen sixty
eight I I was a freshman in high
school.
So I I sure that with the doctor
do not.
And I say that because I was
also a history teacher.
Today in the capital we did a
press conference.
To date March first.
Thousand.
.
Eighteen is the fiftieth
anniversary.
The fiftieth anniversary.
Of walkouts that took out took
place in Los Angeles walkouts
that I. Might. Think that
Alejandro and Manuel may not be
familiar with.
Wild cards.
Ed at Lincoln High School our
field high school Roosevelt high
school. Led by a teacher.
Sal Castro.
The teacher who I had the
opportunity to meet. I had the
opportunity to bring to my
classroom.
It you gotta studies.
My gonna studies classroom in
the high school and I bring it
up because I heard a the handle
and men will talk about. The
importance of teachers and
counselors that look like that.
Like students and I bring it up
because I here Michelle seek
ghettos.
Talking about.
Our students still not being
admitted I hear Michelle talking
about.
Faculty not looking like the
students not not been enough
Latino faculty not having
enough.
Latino administrators not
having enough Latinos on the
regions of the UC. On the board
of trustees of the CSU of the.
Community college.
And guess what.
Those demands of those students
fifty years ago.
Are the same things that we are
talking about today.
The same things those were the
issues that those students
talked about exact the same
things.
So I I don't say that to
discourage us.
I actually say that we need
their energy.
The energy that those students
have and I. Think we do have a.
Right alone.
And they were successful.
Even though here we are fifty
years later and we're talking
about some of the. Things that
we don't have they were actually
were successful.
They they change a culture in
Los Angeles.
Where? No one really expected.
Us.
Latinos to go to college the
change that they turned around
and they did it dramatically. In
the number of students that they
were able to change
they affected. Us a movement.
That. Change now. That made it
possible for me to be in the
state legislature.
Right aye think they created a
movement that that every single
Latino who's ever served in the
state legislature. Up close.
So.
But.
I I think it's it's good that we
take a moment to reflect on
that.
.
And also do use their example to
do better.
Because. Even though there is
much that that we need to
improve the lot.
There is never been a time
where we've had more Latinos in
higher education more Latinos in
you see or Latinos and see
issue.
And and I will quote. Sal
Castro.
And I will quote would settle
Castro said when he came to my
cast my classrooms. Nosair been
they hope.
If you knew Sau Castro that's
who he talked.
You don't go to college.
And about the bottleneck in
community college I was a
community college trustee for
thirteen years.
But it's clear it's obvious
that.
Something's gone wrong with
community college if the
majority of Latinos.
Who are in community colleges
are not being able to? Go to
four year colleges
you know I went to college.
My daughter graduated from U. S.
C. on a graduate of UC
riverside.
We both got out in four years
and that's because we both had
the opportunity to you to be
full time students.
And not have to worry about a
lot of the things that I've
heard the students in the first
panel have to worry about.
But that is what college is
meant to be I think college and
we as a state a California. Need
to do better.
I chair the committee on higher
education I am the subcommittee.
Of on the budget for higher
education it is disgraceful.
I think it is disgraceful the.
Amount of money that we invest
in higher education and so I
make the point that at the time
were there are the most Latinos.
Ever in the history of
California and higher education
it is disgraceful that we kind a
nickel and dime higher
education.
I think we were probably
teaching to the you know
preaching to the choir here with
my colleagues but. It's up to
you.
Its up to you as students to put
pressure. On us to do better so
thank you.
The user Medina.
And the other are questions or
comments from colleagues.
I know nobody it's it's hard to
follow Mr Medina.
The Mister member has the guts
to.
I think you can see why we call
them out profit.
You know I wanted to comment to
Manuel if I could.
I was impressed with your
courage and humility.
And it reminds me. My rates as
well.
My father used to pick grapes in
Pixley and I was born in Delano
so I know make far lent.
And you are right.
That if you come from a humble
place it's our responsibility to
turn around and make sure work
holding that door open for
future generations.
And I was really proud of you
today in your ability to speak
to. To that because.
Thank you doctor Arambula.
.
And with that.
I think we're going to wrap up
this panel.
And move on that.
Public comment.
Thank you very much everybody
for participating.
So now there were thirty five
minutes behind schedule.
This is the opportunity for
public comment thank you
everyone for your patience and
I can with us. So far.
We've allotted technically
thirty five minutes to public
comment.
But really as much time as as
for everyone to be heard.
Those if we check and see if the
microphone is on and we left it
off testing perfect thank you.
So.
The we ask a speakers to love
themselves to one to two minutes
of possible.
In your comments so that we can
hear from as many folks as
possible thank you for your
understanding.
And let me also to say of
please by if you're in the
audience and you want to.
.
Follow along on that the efforts
of the select committee on the
master plan.
And participate in future
hearings don't hesitate to reach
out to my legislative director
Alan green. Of Israeli here in
income and and introduce
yourself and give your contact
information balance.
After the hearing will make
sure that your pride on our
email distribution list
so you're kept up to date on
what we're working on.
.
So that takes care that. And.
With that I'm going to.
Open a public comment with.
And I apologize for.
Minutemen until. Venancio gallon
I'm. A Latino education and.
Issues roundtable perfect
Venancio.
When I started it's good I would
evening.
Thank you Mister Berman I'm blah
honorable Pahlavi articles.
Senator Allen.
Mr Medina.
Which other artists forces
common values thank you very
much for your comments.
A lot of a ground has been
covered our organization has
here six.
Six for six comments we're gonna
try to look I'm gonna try to
limit it to three.
First of all.
Senate bill fourteen forty was
passed in. The year two thousand
ten.
It established a student
transfer achievement Reform Act
sixty units to be.
Stone to be eligible to be
accepted up or year CSU system.
Somehow some way.
Institutions community colleges
did not include.
Say for example. Ethnic studies
Chicano Latino studies
so Senate Billboard for forty
was passed.
Senate for forty says required
the creation of for transfer
model curriculum templates.
That allow students a broader
area of study than previously
available to other associate
degrees for transfer.
It was passed in two thousand
thirteen yet some community
colleges.
We need accountability from you
Mr Medina said.
That community colleges pass
implement this bill.
And not say all students are not
interested in Chicano Latino
studies are not in ruling
because
not part of the sixty transfer
units.
You need to tell them have you
implemented what is already on
the books.
Recommendation to. The master
plan comments have been made
especially by missing Kato's and
others.
About.
Affirmative action which I call
permitted action in the hiring.
We have institutions that four
year colleges.
A nearby use CSU.
That says it all well are. We
have to have. Only ten year.
Teachers.
Tenured professors on the
screening committee that's not
fair that's not equity.
You need across it you can't
have just one let the you know
oh one African American serving
on all the screening committees
because he or she is the only
one. With that degree.
That is tenure.
Finally.
The request.
Last February seventh.
Senator Hueso held. A yeah.
Provided the community this the
majority report.
Sacramento
the Sheraton hotel.
I encourage you.
Especially you assemblyman.
I number now if you could hold
this this report.
Published by the education trust
west.
Have it.
Hell here just like we thank you
very much for the fact that you
had this hearing here.
I no you listen to us because we
recommended that you bring this
here.
We hope that you come back.
And that you have many more
hearings because there are a lot
of concerns.
Finally I like to reiterate that
comment that was made earlier by
cicadas and Mister that on. We
need also representation from
the valley on the CSU the UC
system and especially the
community college or a board of
governors.
A board of regents and the
trustees thank you very much.
Thank you can also.
And next up is Medellin Louden
you see S. B. lobby core.
The reading.
I was a little bit about my
background.
School and my title years of
living up.
Where other read and write to
the?
This is a topic that I've been
with me through it.
Unfortunately for some time
before it hits college and I saw
that it.
It a lot more students than I
was used to.
Irvine.
I really affluent area where
this is
under wraps nobody knew that any
of this going on.
Any friend.
As a junior in high school I
had say give my mom money that
it.
A job orders to cover right.
I and my senior year as my
situation I got words.
And conversations of evictions
turned into threats at least
coming through it or having a
struggle with looking for it.
I've the future and I barely
nearly gave it up to a.
I didn't I.
Here and now.
One I attended UCSB I was
fortunate enough to qualify for
how come.
And was able to have a more
stable and wood living situation
that approved.
Which as Tim had mentioned in
the previous an awful lot of
students experience.
Either way.
But that's just it I you know
my securities based on the
amount of
ability.
I of financial aid.
Cited by.
Leaders which.
Apparently.
My well being is based on the
funding an expert
programs and services on campus
such as mental health. Sexual
assault resources food banks
campus health centers and
countless other programs.
That are suppose to be
available to students.
Weekly different backgrounds and
our various groups on campus.
I from my experience however
lobbying in Sacramento many
legislators have expressed
mistrusted
states.
With working with the UC system
to address funding excuse
which are separate and said the
success.
And experience but students
here at UC system.
While I understand the reasoning
behind it a very.
It is very difficult to not
feel as if they're true archer
realizing her experience
troubles as students.
I just as they can push it aside
as he is trying to get involved
in about it that they don't.
That they don't understand these
conversations.
When in reality every single
student I talked to understand
it much better.
That people up in the level
exact.
These are the lives they live
there not
story can be out.
And that's why I'm here today IV
drip from Senate barber looked
at five in the morning.
You're all day and we're in mid
terms.
Really.
A very interesting times to
leave to go to com.
.
But I'm here today to ask you to
take your afraid to step are
they not just listen to our
voices.
And to not their interests
ten years from now with the
renewal of the master plan. I
would actively fight for the
needs of college students on
housewares in a committee
meetings and in your districts
and
to enact real change.
I think he's.
Thank you know.
And next of his mere.
So Valley health.
Need and thank you for.
Holding this committee hearing
here I live in Fresno of our
organization is headquartered in
Sacramento and I can tell you
many times I have to travel to
Los Angeles o'quinn for
Sacramento. To attend meetings
where I learned about the issues
we here in the Central Valley
say really appreciate you being
here today. And I represent the
Central Valley health network
which is a consortium of
fourteen community health
centers so I don't working
education but we do a lot of
work around work force and while
I recognize the committee had a
hearing. In San Jose around work
force I still think that we want
to bring home the fact that
meeting the needs of students
also means making sure. That the
programs that exist in our
education our going to prepare
those students for terminal
degrees or certificates that
provide them with the skills and
knowledge that they need. To get
living wage career jobs so often
we hear about students
especially in the valley UC
Merced graduates at Sandra. That
are having to take minimum wage
jobs on in places like target or
Taco Bell and places like that.
I'm and so we will feel that and
we need to focus on
problematically.
Something that we take into
consideration as well I mean
that the cost of education
should not outweigh the wages
that these students are going to
be receiving when they enter the
workforce. And saddling them
with such dad.
And doctor regular you know the
shortage of. Health
professionals that we have here
in the Central Valley on as well
as Mr Medina you have the same
thing in the Inland Empire and I
in the. UC riverside along as
well so.
Exactly and and so we have seen
that the impact that that has on
our ability to attract and
retain. Even positions in this
area because they can go to
other areas and make more money
in order to pay off that student
debt.
I also want to talk real quickly
about partnerships I keep with a
colleague and we've had that
workforce leans on because
that's our work.
But what we were sitting here
she had to leave she made the
suggestion that is you look at
things like behavioral health
and and the shortage of. And
that high ratio of counselors to
students when not tap into
partners in the community such
as the federally qualified
health centers. To have
behavioral health services and
other services that they're
providing to the communities
they're very closely located in
many cases to the universities
and maybe if they collaborate
together a group of them. Along
with the education system bill
might be able to help meet some
of those needs without just
fully rely on the government.
So again thank you.
Thank you and much.
Next up is doctor Joseph Jones
followed by Lucy Ruiz.
Thank you all for given the
opportunity I just felt that.
I have a responsibility to be
say something.
I that may be missing out of
president of Fresno Pacific
university.
And what at first I'm new to the
state when I came. I was told
that. It the grand plan of
California which is
best educate.
Was a poor legacy do you all
have for it this.
The at community colleges. It's
the I see it you see. And the
independence.
And so as we're looking at this
massive and I'm hoping. That we
don't forget IV independence
I have to look in terms of just
the data twenty two percent of
the bachelor degrees. Awarded in
the state come from the
independence to about seventy
eight of us.
You six fifty four percent I
think it's fifty to a fifty four
percent of the mask agrees I
come from the independence.
Fifty four percent. Of the five
doctors coming from being
Vincent back about what happens
when the independence.
May have become.
Stifle or handicapped in some
way and quite often they are not
matches in bachelor programs are
supported by what what comes.
On. The.
Back to list programs missiles
with thinking about innocent of
higher education.
We have worked on outcomes we
are really precious about
outcome students don't come to
us I just because of nay become
to us four. Dozen outcomes
we have Fresno Pacific we have a
four year guarantee.
If you don't do it for years and
we have all of wraparound
service you don't go in for
years.
Three for Yasser that we've been
working with this compact.
About a two year guarantee and
we met with the presidents of
the community colleges
without even working with Fresno
state. Up a little when I hear
became having more acid down
with president would aye Joseph.
What can we do we appear to
actually do something and work
in the valley?
Nine five percent of our student
body a California residents
yes a young aye ninety two
percent of those students are
act or scholarship fifty four
percent of Boston.
Come from families of forty on
with incomes of less of forty
thousand
so population is not much
different and if you look at
the.
I'll be independence
sixty percent of the population
students of color and and Fresno
Pacific sixty two percent.
A lot population
students of color subpopulations
out much different music and we
haven't had to work very hard to
act and make sure that. Obvious
dot Carlock.
Return on investment
we greatly appreciate.
And the support of the cal
grants are but of one of the
things that really appreciate
when I'm here because there is.
And now causes the universe is.
Coming together and act of talk
about how can we are to have any
impact. On this ballot. Up for
the students that I in this
valley we have regional campus
I'm biggest buildup to Merced.
So how can we have to work
together I do do that and not
trying to are compete globally
working up the have impact. I
think that. As you think about
the master plan on who else is
doing it
yeah I guess of new.
But I think it's a great idea if
you really are trying to have.
Impact on education I also this
and I'll and I'll the yeah I
worked in the I would be a city.
Feel just as I was a professor
in that particular field by
working I feel years
as always thinking a reason why
I've connected with education
and just.
By the up you'll probably have
seen the reports because it came
from legislative legislative
analyst's.
Report says that it's over
seventy thousand dollars a year.
Fought in makes in prison.
That's what we're spent. So as
we think about education and
investing.
Well we should be acting up be
reluctant at in terms of how we
are looking at the list
wraparound services
it we need all over. Actually
students at the retain graduate
income I can get a job and start
businesses and invest in.
And the state and so I just want
you to remember.
We ought independence
seventy. We have capacity will
read that really to go to part
with all of the.
See if you.
The community colleges and is
the thank you. Think.
You got to Jones makes it will
lose you moody's.
That followed by Amelia Medina.
Thank you chair Berman obviously
I'm not loosing.
Although confused that he was
going to put
I mean down.
Put her on me and I I want to
take this opportunity first and
foremost Israel has no you are.
John Leo fees eight center
community college
trustee the user last year. I
want to thank welcome home.
Dr Arambula and I want to a
welcome and thank you for being
here.
For this very important session
and I know that you we've had a
lot of information I'm only here
to echo and support all of our
speakers.
And we have a chance to here we
have a doctor go goldsmith here
community college president we
are working to other.
Here with others in a in the
consortium
to improve our situation you've
heard all the facts and figures.
And we just hope that you will
act upon that.
And again thank you for coming
thank all of you for
participating. And I really
appreciate it thank you thank
you very much.
Next we in the million Martinez
followed by just heard.
De she's meet Justin WCO.
Hello my name is an idea or.
And.
I'm first generation second
year student you see I. Saw
before I continue on a shadow.
And I am you know I think credit
should be given god is doing a
thing.
Something's politicians don't
get to have the best route but I
I think you've been a great
advocate for us we really
appreciate that.
Site she missed that along with
other students we missed a day
of lecture during week eight to
be here. Arm so I really hope
that what I'm about to say it's
not just another comment that
you hear and they forget about
it.
Because plus to be here we had
to drive about.
So.
Mattress yeah you see.
You see I I worked three jobs
to make sure I wouldn't have to
take out any loans.
I was a full time student and I
also chair for center Cunningham
Leyva enables her staff to make
sure I always see it was her
staff to show me what loans
where. We do have an online
training program we to go alone
but it's.
It's nine up there needs to be
more.
It one of her staff members
actually graduate from you see I
saw was her on the with me
about.
Things that I needed to do to
find different resources I
think.
You know that shows that we have
a long way to to me students
need done their respective
campuses.
I'm Matt now second year I
figure some things out like part
thirty park twenty minutes away
so you pay less for parking.
Join the team that ambassadors
so they'll give you dying
dollars so you can save some
money on food.
Going to add at high speeds vote
class account and try to find
that the tide of your books
before anyone else can so you
can find the book at the library
and scanned.
So you don't have to pay for
them share the clickers with
fancy don't have to pay the
fifty to seventy five dollars
keep for them and hope you get
caught doing so. Because you're
supposed to eat registered only
one click a per person.
.
Yeah and US government relations
director at high to make it upon
myself to make sure that I every
lobby core meeting. We have food
so the students participating
ABA.
Some of them get at least one
good meal an entire week.
I shouldn't have to do that.
.
Because you know as tuition
increase says we have a. We have
a proposed tuition increase vote
coming up in.
I fishing increases fewer
students from low income
backgrounds apply even when they
are eligible for financial aid.
That thing about low income
students is that we need so much
more than just. Financial way
there's so many things that
comes with fees according travel
up to get there I commute for
forty minutes if my parents had
only their car I wouldn't be
able to make it to you see I.
So there's so much more things
than needs to be done and I
think.
I think this is a first grade
staff I am happy that this is
something that would going and I
hope moving forward it continues
with even more momentum day
house right now because I.
This should be packed.
And.
Yeah I I think there's
something that needs to be done
either from you all or I don't
know anyone else but some things
to be done to.
To be able to give a stipend or
something to students to make it
out to do things like this
because it is difficult for us
to to do this.
I'm not I think we have a key
for other things that we
ourselves experience. So.
You know somethings from ya to
have us at the table.
I know you've heard this all
before.
And I know this process is long
I know that's that thing in
politics but please Piper this
like your career depends on it.
It the state of California has
achieved unbelievable any times
in your on no that is.
We'd take risk when no one else
dares to we think yes we can and
yes we welcome people shy away.
This is the Californians very
and we don crazy things before.
Funding all students should not
be something that which I away
from.
.
All over the state students have
that done in this time thank you
continue to join us.
Thank you they you million.
Next it was just and honest you
know.
Followed by pearl Flores.
Forgive me if I ramble of it aye
Andrew over three hundred.
Four hours of sleep to get.
So little packet of this coffee
in the back.
Yeah.
No who.
So little background on me I.
And.
There.
I. Came here I was really
interested in this.
I was I'm student I lived under.
A pass of the fifteen.
For several years because my
parents were drug at.
And I was holding first grade.
Again in fifth grade again and
eleventh grade that college
wasn't.
And that was something that I
really internalized M..
And it really her and I never
thought I would be at a you see
and I would be if.
Student leader.
But here I am.
One of the things that I think
is important to know is that we
do have a seat here funding
issue.
.
When I hear a tuition increases
and then I look at like the sea
otter reportedly
I see office of the president I
get extremely fast.
Because I have to make that
choice in order to come here I'd
exhaust.
The cast.
And we're actually Kiley rented
aye aye.
Absolutely exhausted my bank
account to get here today.
So it's really hard for me.
Knowing that I'm not.
We able.
And when I get frustrated when
aye we to get food or other
resources.
Yes I get will growl.
And I look at myself and I
realize I'm one of the lucky
so I was a C. C. transparent.
Aye was one of the lucky ninety
two percent that actually got
through. I'm in the reason why
as I took seventeen to twenty
five units every quarter. Or
every semester.
She Dillon roll into community
colleges in order to
I'm over an admissions.
Because I have and taking care
my grandma who is can't.
And I understood that if I
didn't get my
I agree I would be.
And it's so when you're looking
at legislation I urge you to
remember that all of you all
most likely have always had act.
Those
you will never know the shame
and degradation going into first
grade being taken very ending.
That was my first real
experience that happened again
in third and fourth grade and it
was awful.
And so coming to from a place
about a lack of privilege it
means a lot to be able to speak
up and actually look at.
Senator for example in the eye
and say Hey this is me this is
my name and I.
And then the closing remark that
I would really like to make is.
I don't know if I necessarily
agree with a point made about
fifteen to graduate plan and the
only reason that I do I disagree
with that.
I work extensively everything
psycho need seventy miles
because I do not.
They riverside area.
I was almost home once again by
my best friend and her family
took me and so I was able to.
Live album in a very comfortable
house
duration but it's.
Everyday I
how did your on him I going to
eat warming up he began.
And then when they get to
school I work twelve to fifteen
hour days every single day
sometimes I get home at three or
four in the morning. And have to
week of ATM and we go back.
So that's about a two hour drive
his single day.
Really exhausting I don't get
any additional support.
And I'm lucky if my financially
coverage even a fraction of any
of the cost.
Especially because my car is
eighteen years old I had a
secret for years to Alaska
hundred dollars.
A paper. I'm an attack breaks
down then high have.
I one of the lucky slick think
about the person and I am lucky
there so many students that have
the exact same story the exact
same
Akram. That aren't as lucky that
will never ever get to step out
on use.
It's I really want children
think about that when you look
at budgets and release that were
more than just.
Just.
Next with a pro of was followed
by LEN inquiry.
Good evening everyone and first
of all I wanted to think.
Fresno City College for having
is here and actually everyone is
in this room like I'd like to
thank you.
Because it means a lot to not
just me but every person here is
here for a reason and they know
that together we're gonna stand
and fight for what we believe.
So my name is Philip Florence
and I'm a missionary Xin first
year student at the university
of California riverside.
And is a psychology major I've
always wanted to make a
difference in the world but.
I get there I have to call.
And.
Financially that makes it very
difficult.
If tuition was to go out I'd be
forced to get their job to pay
off my.
My parents can help me with
money because in the end I'm
actually hoping that.
Then I'm not unemployed because
they choose to.
My mother has the duty to take
care my youngest five year old
sister.
And my. Father suffers from a
disability and due to racism in
his workplace my father has been
unjustly rocked of money like
not being paid overtime.
When he works it.
And as a little girl I was never
really able to see my father.
And he would always leave it don
early morning and arrived very
late and when you're little you
tend to sleep early. And
sometimes I remember I would
always way at night image that
his dad coming home. Centers
like no he has to stay over
there at work.
And sometimes I made it even
harder to for me because I
wouldn't even seem on weekends.
.
Now.
And he worked excessively
basically to support the life of
the skits.
And now I'm paying off college
on my own and trying to support
my family this.
Raising tuition would force me
to take a job that would take
away the time I need to study
and do other work.
Such as like internships or
being here.
I am sure I'm not the only
student you've heard with the
story. But I know we all have a
bunch of potential and all we
ask is not.
And hard.
The.
People.
Next up we're letting Cooley a
fall by Tom who.
Good evening everyone.
Or express my sincere gratitude
to on presence on sit on the
city community college. I'm Fred
I'm not only I think we've been
able to have this kind of
meeting also having students
come to present. A book during a
public forum on my name is on
legislative your current.
The number is an eleven
including.
Apparently if pursue political
science major at university
called for your riverside.
Before I begin I want to ask
every respective committee
members to imagine a life where
a college education
and is.
Deemed as unattainable simply
due to economic status.
Once which is the reality for
many students across
see UC and CSU system arm
including myself coming from the
home of immigrants the topic of
on. Immigrants from was who
other medical.
The topic of a college
education would always often of
one. On to postpone the
conversation
about.
Affording to pay for one.
It was from a young age that I
quickly up with knowledge that a
college education was needed for
social mobility to break the
cycle financial information.
I'm I'm here today not only to
represent them the minority once
on this kind of issue. But
specifically use yours with the
next on student population who
do not have the privilege of
presenting a fund
fine folk here today.
Cho in the little over then
little over than fifty bombs
fifty percent of you see our
students receive the program
however is still report
understood large through
external publishes report that
their food and secure.
Specifically because the public
doesn't cover for things such as
books etcetera.
.
During my little time at UC
riverside being in government.
Relations assistant director of
had the opportunity to
what externally outside of you
see riverside and within the
seize riverside student
population I'm having students
come up to me and tell me that.
On the fact that they have to
skip meals in order to buy books
on the fact that was a lot of
students are homeless and didn't
have anywhere to.
To go during the summer it said
a little little over little weak
winter breaks.
With kindest heart mean and it
makes you run Billy second guess
what. Where are Senate of
senator members
what are the assembly members
doing to make sure that?
Students are represented and to
have to go to do this kind of
struggles.
As a minority voice I call the
committee not only to focus our
efforts to create a high.
Headmaster plan that addresses
student basic needs one that
provides equity for students of
color think.
Even.
Tom moved be followed by Taylor
Chumley.
Good afternoon chairman and
members my name's Tom for them
with the association of in the
California colleges and
universities say I see see you.
How we are the organizational
boys for seventy eight private
prop
colleges and universities?
?
Let me just many move. Right
about it.
I just want to quickly touch on
a couple of things.
This past Tuesday we had ours
annual student lobby day.
And we were joined by president
Jones but he just laughed.
.
We over a hundred twenty cal
grant students from across the
state came up to the capitol to
meet with legislators and or
staff.
About the points of.
The cow when work and the
points of maintaining it at nine
thousand eighty four.
The award has not seen increase
since two thousand.
And the has actually decreased
by thirty five percent.
Over the last decade due to
inflation and also cuts.
As tickets noted.
The cal grant is an integral
part of access and success
especially for first generation
students and students from
disadvantaged communities.
From.
The cabin students in the
nonprofit sector a do extremely
well.
There they have a sixty two
percent four year graduation
rate. At in the nonprofit
sector.
I think this exemplifies the
wraparound services that
president Jones mentioned in
when he was up here.
.
That are nonprofit college can
provide to struggling students.
We're grateful that the world
will not be cut this year.
But we just want to know that
is stable and hopefully
increasing.
Cal grant award.
Will help students access and
succeed.
In the nonprofit sector of the
second point very quickly.
A I see see you is working on a.
Variation of the associate
degree for transfer program.
That would create a strong
transparent pathway for transfer
students.
To access.
More options.
When they look at what they
want transfer and that we hope
that you can support that this
year thank you.
Seventy which only fall back.
Dinesh.
.
Can quickly as the last man
died.
Possibly.
To have all those most.
Intimate.
No to.
Dinesh.
.
Yeah they were the last manager
might. Be dashed big bash aye
match. Five.
Well another.
But high ambition I a good
evening out on the legislative
director from the student union
assembly. On how you see
senators that are sitting
government body.
And so I was already thinking
the committee members were here
today particularly.
Assembly member.
I had the option to speak in
front of you at the assembly sub
you budget hearing last week and
diets.
One person you hear once again
fighting for students
and on behalf.
But.
Yeah well I don't to drove you
know three hours with my peers
to get here I am here.
And I'm here at this hearing
because I could afford to me
right I'm privileged enough to
be here to be able to skip
class.
To not rely on minimum wage
jobs to for my tuition I'm in my
basic needs but. We also to
remember that there were folks
who couldn't be here today
we have to remember that so some
folks were two sometimes three
jobs and are enrolled as full or
part time students.
Here within the you see who
couldn't be here because they
can't just work.
What class?
It's important also recognize
what all of us to do therefore
get in return. For the work be
putting.
Within this broken system that
to stay within it.
We sure hope that this hearing
several two sticks backing up
this narrative about you know
lack of resources lack of basic
needs and those statistics
represent us but. They're also
you know representative real
students real stories and a
total lack of access to
affordable housing and food. So
just budget is six rate you see
things home to the fort worth
small city in the.
U. S. were renters we do not
have a designated.
Site for.
Housing are libertarian Regis
defenders of not spent but
tuitions as well as I'm just of
actions are moon plans are
expensive our food pantries
under are underfunded.
So what do all of us what we
want greater state investment.
In all areas of public
education and this committee
albeit you know a small step is
a step in the right direction.
But it will only mean something
if it's efforts are continuous
and center student voices and I
can't emphasize that enough so
I'm to all of you to carefully
listen to the student stories.
Take them to heart understand
that there is a lot of emotional
and physical labor put into
coming here. And to work to
change the pope deplorable state
of our current.
Thank you.
And next up we have.
Who?
We their.
Some love Mister or Mrs Elliott.
To have an.
What is it?
Cameron thank you Cameron
followed by Alison lira.
You guys for coming.
I think it'll be here
got us out of.
Enhance higher education.
As a collective.
From by scantily I'm a first
year student. I see senators
I'm a part of the student union
the.
DR student I UC Santa Cruz.
I'm as big has said.
We're all provision of to be
here.
And so afford to miss a day of
school. And not have to worry.
To pay tuition.
I mean that's can attain for me
it will soon hereby.
Yeah.
.
Was brought up earlier was that.
The state Senate more students I
understand this.
Transfer students
are not transferring.
To.
Bob for universities.
Because.
It's there is not space.
But.
A problem.
You see senators I capacity.
Like in every way shape and
form.
Buses are.
Till date leave the station but
our.
Without admitting every student
who was waiting at the bus stop
suits have to wait longer.
Classes are completely full
since who needs to take
directors instead declare
majors.
Cannot do that and as a result
or staying for longer than four
years at the institute.
.
Yes and the solution to this. Is
the bottom. Simply find the
university system.
The way it should be.
.
I was brought up earlier as
well.
Was an emphasis on mental
health.
UC Santa Cruz has.
And is tuition called.
Caps which is the.
Counseling and psychological
services.
Department at our school.
We of are currently staffed at a
ratio of one to seventeen
hundred.
Students to faculty ratio there.
And after four sessions.
At that institution you're
referred off campus.
Assuming you can even afford to
go there insurance covers.
So. Also. That's funded by
student fees and not by.
Anything else systems are paying
for this.
I think I want to bring out.
Was very pantries.
We have one fifty insurance our
campus serving.
All of seventy thousand students
undergraduate. And graduate
students as well.
Battling his by the sunset was
established Patterson
government.
The future is uncertain because
it is
the space is help them.
Isn't helpers which is our
office for.
That's for education and
recreation sports.
So the gem and sports and all
that sort of way.
And it's not the spaces and
designated.
That was established by the
student.
Not by any sort of.
Tuition or administrative body.
.
Currently public.
Sam go are not on nobody has the
right spoke about this. Is
working to.
Change order coffee shops.
Entry.
Their places and.
And I just think it's astounding
that students have to take upon
themselves.
To.
Perform services that should.
Should be.
Under their.
Should be their problem.
This question we paid tuition
that is so expensive.
And were.
Right with it being a raise this
year.
.
The housing crisis better
addressed as well. Private
match.
Will be a.
Technology by Anthony listeners
will someone just.
You see my type thing has
brought me here.
You can.
That's seven Alison the phone by
and then you've
Biondo.
I am out clear and in the third
year you see.
So the last couple of years. And
I've been helping my sister and
my cousin.
Piper college.
And it's been a really special
time because.
Were all family the migraines
and.
Were all were going to be the
first generation in our family
to go and.
And everyone took said in the
ruins of proud but at the same
time there's just so much wary
involved. I'm in applying
because over the last couple
years in this process and going
to college myself it's become so
clear that. And access to higher
education access the pap that if
you do your dreams and.
Is like so hard and and it's not
just getting into your dream
school I don't know how to tell.
My cousins on huntsman sister
that link.
Getting there and and
maintaining access to that the
school your dream sometimes
require skipping sometimes
requires working with will just
suddenly fires.
Like not being able to study in
failing a test and having to
deal with that so.
We need to do better all of us
need to do better and.
There are so many kids out there
with so much ambition with.
That are so smart and so bright
who do not get the opportunity
and who feel like. They can't
and and it's just it's a shame
and needs to better.
Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you also.
Matt Simmons in Geneva Miano
followed by to be so what what
what Kira watcher.
It I like to see.
To non your being here at this
meeting. I'd like to I think the
committee for giving me the
opportunity to talk about.
Some of the green issues I of
witnessing experience at my
university UC Santa Cruz.
And I want to start by saying my
name is Anthony far beyond I'm a
first year student.
And.
.
I saw freshman starting
university in the fall of two
thousand seventeen nam I felt
very excited phone very on.
Grateful to witness some of the
opportunities to be given to me
summaries his I could
potentially like take advantage
off.
But I wanted to talk and stress
about like some of the issues
regarding the relationship
between housing and over
enrollment. At my university.
And.
Throughout the year I've
witnessed the school crammed
thousands of students in to
various housing units but just
don't have the capacity or the
utilities.
To fit a like most of these
people.
And.
Mayor Dorn such as mine are
often very crowded and it's
very.
Not it does not not suitable for
living conditions.
.
For me this transformation was
very comfortable to handle.
Some of the utilities in my
dorm are often exhausted to the
point of having electrical
blackouts. Clogged toilets sinks
and.
Shower drains as well as.
Various colleges like broken
doors.
Broken window sometimes
broken washing machines and
dryers.
And.
You know living in a small room
with two other roommates who
have various stuff.
We can often prove very up
claustrophobic to me sometimes
as well as being very affected
to my allergies I often. As a
person with a history of asthma
Idaho often proves like very.
Stressful to. Be comfortable and
then like very stressful to.
To sleep as well so I often
found myself witnessing that
I've been prone to be more sick
often I've.
Often god are groups like.
Sore throats nam very runny
noses and I often found myself
going to the health center like.
Every month or so.
And.
It may seem simple to just say.
Make a simple request maybe
find yourself a single room bite
on the weightless is
astoundingly long because of how
many students are enrolled at
UCSC.
That the most likely response
and I would receive would be.
Next year in the fall of two
thousand eighteen.
And.
Because of this I also have to
juggle the stresses of studying
for my finals on winter quarter
and also. Knowing where am I
going to live next year one my
going to live with and how we
gonna figure out the costs and
stuff like that.
So.
I just wanted to ask you all
like to St questions to consider
power as you go on today.
And.
Number one was.
Since it has been reported that
the state of California's
project began a sixty seven
million dollars billion dollars
not million dollar surplus.
Look good proportion of the
garden that had very of
situations that. California
public institutions are
currently facing.
And number two is what is
currently the best planned to
have to conduct some of these
issues.
And with number three on with
all of us residing in the state.
That holds some of the world's
greatest learning institutions.
Dear how these great colleges
are slowly deteriorating.
Israel arming and disheartening
for me.
Myself and thousands of other
students in the UC system.
Calyces system and California
community college system are
provided the proper amount. And
quality of the services needed
to survive and grow.
Then how do expect our
generation those support the
next generation of college
students think.
Next it was. Three so what
you're. Memories you know Troma.
Hello everyone my name is that I
saw she to and I'm to
externalize president for the
associated students of UC Merced
as well as the campaign chair
for you see a say. I'm I'm here
today up to make sure to ask
that you.
Put more funding in higher
education and I want to start by
telling you my narrative of how
I got
see in my journey in the.
US so four years of high school
fun times.
My to ninety the classes I was
involved added student
government I'm putting on top of
them making sure that I was
attracted to the you see I was
also. I'm acting as a parent for
my
stirs up because my parents were
busy right they had to work in
order for me to go to college.
And so I did well I went my if
I did my first semester I did
really well I got on the honor
system.
And then I come home over
winter break in my parents but
the news that I to resettle the
can go back to this semester. I
UC Merced rate for years I spent
juggling a. Training I like that
for years I spent drug juggling
student governments to delay my
AB because
even with my
stirs right making sure that
they go to school making sure
that they were. Clean making
sure they eight making sure they
were fed like I was practically
is up appearance my sisters
right at the age of fourteen I
was taking care of three peat.
Right.
And for all of that hard work
to go down to the guard
because my parents couldn't
afford.
.
Could not afford it for me to
stay at UC Merced rate.
So I hope that you are taking
my narrative.
Into consideration right you
have people.
To spend so much time and
energy just to get here right
and now that we got here we
don't have the resources to
sustain us.
Great I'm I don't think it
should be this difficult right I
don't have reek I don't know the
resources offered to member side
because I'm an immigrant rate.
Idea how parents I could talk to
it and how my grandparents I
could
two I was the first one in my
heart and my family to attend a
forty university.
So I don't have aye the
opportunity or resources or
whatever that my school provided
I didn't know about that
I rate aye again democratic. I
came here when I was three like.
But we do nothing we just knew
each other that's that's what I
had my family
right into going to college
right not having my family not
having my support system. Right
but also are having to
like having the two three wait
two three week wait to go to
catch.
That's absurd great so making
sure that your also putting
money into
I hope resources.
Because Merced has
highest percentage of appeal see
students write low income
students but no way to support
them great we don't have.
Our campus ray our food pantry
is once a month on.
Our food pantries and accessible
to students
right so making sure that you
are putting money into higher
education to suspend your
students right because. We
shouldn't be working three jobs
they also juggling art class.
To make sure we're now if you
really want to get
fired up within a career eight
so I I really ask that you are.
Taking everything they were
saying its current
consideration.
In that you find that you see
fund this use use fund the
community colleges.
Because if you do all of my
sisters will be
my siblings will be here and now
my goal is to graduate right
making sure I make money.
My sisters can
colleges because my parents
because I'll be the one who has
to raise them
ray because my parents are
getting old. In that will be my
responsible
so I'm back to square one I'm
back to being a parent great
when I should be an older sister
Y. should be a mentor. Right.
So.
Patrol consider that.
Thank you very much.
They do is a next will Mauricio.
We should draw.
Good afternoon.
Many Israelis your trade hope.
I I'm an undergraduate a
undocumented working class
incident leader at the nurses
California Merced. I currently I
serve of the organizing director
for the external office of
associations summer said and
have the privilege of serving on
the executive board. Of the UC
stern association of the campus
action chair.
At the bay at the young age of
eight years old.
By a single mother and my
family decided to migrate out
United States.
Worried I'd recited an Orange
County garden Grove California.
How mean to navigate a the
American culture learn the
language and about myself into a
society that the not necessarily
view me as a potential? For this
they are even to anything I had
to fight and been for resources
are going up the single mother I
to begin working at a young age
of two years old. Where I would
do a construction work?
While at the same time
balancing my education.
When I began high school.
A people around me were
thinking and talking about going
to college you're thinking about
possibilities and they're
gaining themselves.
Those necessity opportunities
to get their.
So now I continue to push
myself and I could to push
myself to get there but the same
time balancing the work.
In being involved in the
community that was part of being
a are a mentor to a lot of
people that were around me who
are like myself and document.
So I saw myself applying to
college apply to see if you seen
UC's which none of them.
I never I didn't meet their
standards I wasn't a step the
twenty the universe isn't it and
the to buy decided appeal my
with of the system.
Wimp that's where I ended up
are you see Merced now you see
Merced considers it opens panics
or institution with.
I believe it's a sin eighty
percent of people of color first
generation low income students
yet Merced does not have the
resources to retain insisting
the students have a threesome
mention. Are we have an off
campus food pantry and curly
fifty percent of the Somerset
student undergraduate students
based food insecurity water at
the system level it's forty six
percent. That's eleven percent
more than system wide using
research students are facing
footage occurs and I really
think about that we live in the
Central Valley would newly. Food
is grown here yet students not
December said not to students
but people in the own commuting
the center by the are going
hungry.
I'm so I'm here today because
arm once I arrive to you see
Merced arm I was pushed to go to
higher education as a way to
liberate myself. But the same
time I was not able to find the
retention the leader and being a
student
worker I work for service
my documents.
At this.
The advising center first
the social sciences humanities
and arts and I serve as a mentor
for ask me thirty to.
The unions not but the same time
were forced to be able to find a
pen these resources as you see
today we have no administrators
from the summer so that came.
And had this conversation with
you are there's an issue there
we need a love to find. Both the
UC system the CSU system and the
CS you are in the commuter
cartilages we today we talked
about equity we talked about
inclusion we talked about the
adversity. We talk about
economic and social.
Just this year we can how these
conversations it were provided
and now I'm packing the
systematic barriers for students
to thrive in these systems were
not.
Finding the solutions as I'm
here for you as I'm by applying
to graduate and op exam levels
are hard for me. As a we just
have eyes with in person county
just this past week I mean we're
not doing anything to actively
protect our students and
protect.
Their.
Their sustainability within the
systems any other issue a. Thing
you
know you're welcome good evening
everybody my name to the locust
you I attend here have Fresno
City.
I'm secretary of the velocity
club in a member of the pathway
to law.
Program it's a pipeline.
Program designed to diversify
the demographics and prepare and
inspire students to pursue a
career in law. On their to
provide representation for
people like me
something that the lock rear
like many are missing.
Like Mr Medina mentioned here we
are again asking for people like
us faculty like a staff like
because it center alright. I
move on to the U. S. that. Is
approaching twenty trillion a
common term that's being used.
Some students.
Acquire dead before they go on
to college so students acquire
debt. When they're in college.
So students who become
individuals and going to the
workforce.
Leave college graduating college
with day. My so. It makes me
wonder.
Are we being condition and
accustomed to debt. Is a trickle
down effect more of a rhetorical
question.
Speaking a debt Berkeley law
program with housing is over
eighty one.
Three easily over to.
Let me see.
Like.
Many people.
Who spoke up here depend on
grants?
In order for them them stay in
school to pay for bare
necessities.
Basic needs right like Spencer
mentioned one of the speakers at
the very beginning.
So the trump administrators all
this is my question to you to
the panel.
But open ministration is seeking
to cut north three billion over
five percent from the education
department while I'm.
One point
billion.
Por private school vouchers.
Other school choice programs.
The creek bed key proposed
changes.
Cuts several discretionary grant
programs.
Which many people smoke appeared
depend on.
Grants including the DC tuition.
Aid program number question is
what stands for actions are
being taken to prepare for this
change on your and. And what
steps and or actions do you
recommend students to prepare
for for this change.
Thank you my name's Danilov
Castillo I attend friend.
Fresno City here.
.
Right yeah they think.
They don't see him what one more
comment one more public comment
there. Please le let us know
your name.
My name is for money managers
Ortega and I am from Fresno
state university. I am actually
from an organization known as if
you the students quality
education. And I am a CFA and
turn.
On and so.
Everything has gone wrong say hi
I lost my notes.
.
And the odd turn it inside up on
the right place you doing great
but I don't read.
I just came here to say on.
I have shown good food
insecurity I have actually used
those student pantry on campus.
And.
It's not as great as they made
it seem in the panel on a lot of
time the food there is spoiled.
So we kinda have to get the food
and hope that it it still
edible.
Are in addition I work right now
we are facing.
Apostolate tuition increase for
the second year in a row. On we
are actually planning on going
over to Sacramento and asking
governor brown for one funding
for its use you.
Because on something that we
notices that as on.
As the morning students of color
had entered to see if you use
the lighter on this the funding
for his issues has become
lighter. And we feel that that
is not right we want us we want
something someone up full of
money. For this is to use so
that our own federal would have
to show it this every year.
Because on.
We actually had a could I. Cook
convinced nam poorer part of.
We're gonna at issue is of
worker sees member here at and
Fresno. On we committed to
putting gas increase but it took
awhile because.
Did he see he thought that that
was the only way that it on see
if you can be funded. But this
this year they decided to on
allows.
To proposes budget before the
decision felt that is why we are
going to Sacramento and we're
hoping to take as many
people who can
we are at actually I want to
invite all of you. To come with
us to Sacramento to ask for the
funding.
You Mister there. Arambula it's
your Medina Mister Allen. Mister
Berlin. I hope you can join us
and everyone else here we have
people here from rise who I hope
will join us all. On wheels at a
sea of that he has the same
number and I hope that they can
join us also. Thank you thank
you very much.
So then Mr Allen has a plane to
catch in about forty five
minutes yeah so I mean I'm
really you go.
But but let me I'd like to say.
That there's a group of senators
that are gonna be proposing and
by out of the tuition increases
from the new budget I would.
Love to have my colleagues.
We would certainly love to hear
about when not rallies can.
Sure you'll have a number of
members who.
.
You know eight it said I was
very touched by the comments
that were made.
And I members hearing a lot of
these
when I was.
The board of regents
in member and and
sad to me how.
How are how many of the problems
that we talked about and having
yet been solved effect in some
respects it gotten worse?
With with the situation and in
Washington
nothing else so I'm I I really
appreciate everyone being.
So far and I know the hardships.
You took to to to get here and I
am.
We're gonna work hard to try to
turn around so that extra money
it's in the budget to help
address. Some of these
affordability questions.
And I just encourage you to keep
this advocacy up your passion
your
it's area your stories I think
are very moving and very
telling.
I need to bring him to more
elected officials need to bring
into the governor you can bring
into the.
Members of Congress represent
Central Valley members the
legislature's well.
So they will take those those
voices with them when they're
making
visions in.
And Washington in Sacramento
site I really do appreciate
everybody's call.
Thank you the center.
It'd make an opening statement
so I. Feel good about making a
closing statement.
But to the student from Santa
Barbara. That.
Don't first let me thank.
Everyone including.
Fresno community college.
And I chair for having is here.
But I think what you're doing
and what you're saying here
today is exactly what. I senator
Allen said. Needs to continue to
happen.
It is too often in Sacramento
that we look at numbers. And not
individuals
so if the students will continue
to do what they've done here
today. But they did in
Sacramento a couple weeks ago.
And bring more students with
you.
And bring more stories with you
so that the legislature and the
governor here's the effect. Of
what we're doing in Sacramento
on your individual lives I think
we'll do better so thank you.
Especially the students from UC
riverside everything is
imminent.
That Arambula we don't have
anything.
I.
Was moves today.
You know I'm encouraged to think
that our community will look
like what we saw today.
That this advocacy that you are
doing is inspiring so many of us
means a lot.
And I just wanted to say thank
you to all the students who took
time out.
I know it's not easy I know it's
not check.
But we need to hear your voices
and I just wanted to thank you
for your time.
Thank you doctor are like.
So so lastly.
I this woman think don't think
everyone here today but I
suppose he wants to think the
students.
That came today and and
participated I'm told us your
stories whether was on the
panels are during public
comment.
Especially considering how far
many of you traveled but to get
here I want to say that you know
I make sure that you hear us.
And I promise you that we hear
you.
And